はい それではよろしくお願いします
今日のテーマのお話に入ります
えーと まあ今日は早く終わると思います
それから皆様もいろいろ質問とかあるならば出してみてください
今日のテーマですね まあちょっとここから見えますね
で ムディタの実践から始まる幸福論ということで
まあムディタっていうのは
まあ一応喜びという感じに翻訳されています
はい これからこのまあテーマに入ります
この嫉妬っていうことはね
定義する必要もないんです
普通は私は定義から始まりますけど
なぜかというと この嫉妬は悪いということは
まあまあ 仏教でなくてもね
一般的によくまあ知られていることで
昔からもね まあどんな世界でも嫉妬は良くないことだと知ってるんですね
ですから あえて仏教はまあそれを定義する必要はないし
まあ定義はありますけど
今日はいろいろたくさん経典のデータも集めたんですけども
一つも使わなかったんですね
それでまあ来る前に じゃあまあ念のためにプリントでもしようかなと思ってプリントしようと思ったら
プリンターに断られて
まあインクがないんだから中止しますと
じゃあまあいいやということで
まあまあ 定義とかいろいろありましたけどね
で これは面白いことがありましてね
あの 嫉妬があるかないかと知るためには
やっぱりいろんな人々とね
仲良くしなくちゃダメなんですね
だから 人間と関係を持って生活すると現れる現象なんですね
そういうことで 昔のね
もう今もう時々出家のお坊さんたちがね
一人で生活をしているんです
でもそれって結構やばいんです
一人で生活すると 自分には嫉妬心があるかどうか分からなくなるでしょうに
だから発病しなきゃ治療もできんでしょう
そこは結構 昔からの出家の世界では結構問題になるんですよ
で 瞑想してもしても 嫉妬の精神がある限りは成長しないんです
このままいっとっかかっちゃうんですね
だからお坊さんって知らないんですね
お坊さんたちは なんでこんな真面目に瞑想しているのに
もう全然何の成長もないでしょうかとかね
って悩んだりはするんです
それから この この微妙にこの微妙なところで
どうでもいいところで
この出家の方々の心の中でも嫉妬が出てくるんですよ
例えば森の中で生活したっても
二人三人でね 一人が例えば庭とかね
まあこの出入りする道とかね
掃除しますね 掃除はとてもきれいとかね
自分がやっちゃうとなかなかうまくいかないとかね
そんな程度のことにでも嫉妬してしまうんです
あるいは一人のお坊さんが声が結構美しくて
そうすると信者さんとかはね
その人を喋っているとそう聞いているんでね
それで他のお坊さん この人対して仏教も知らないくせに
よくベラベラ喋るんだなとかね
って思ったりするんですね
だからそういうところで嫉妬もありますけど
なかなか本人にそれ言いつらいんですね
君 これ嫉妬だよと 気をつけろよと
で だから俗世間の嫉妬とすごく微妙なんですね
あの人 そんな嫉妬じゃないでしょ
あの人は本当に仏教をよく学んでないだろうにと
だからもっと仏教を知っている先輩のお坊さんたちいるならいるんだから
質問に答えたり 在家の方々に話したりするのは
その長老たちの仕事なのになんであの人これをやってるんですか？と
私はただまあ正しいことを言ってるだけだというふうに自分をまあ
ごまかしてしまっちゃうんですね
だから嫉妬があるということを発見することも大事なことなんです
だから この出家生活している
この道場とかね そういうところに住むと
生活しているお坊さんたちにとっては
なかなか汚れの発見できないというハンディがあるんです
普通にすごく真面目に生きているんですね
だから 自分の心には全然問題ないんだよと思ってしまいますね
しっかりやっているんだと
そんな甘い話でもないんですね
仏教は科学的ですから
心にこの細菌があるかないか
その細菌を取り除かなきゃいけないんですね
だから 細菌があるかないかとテストしなきゃわからないでしょう
だから ああいう環境でいるとテストできないんですね
はい そういうことで この嫉妬っていうのは
この特に社会生活するともう派手に出てくるものなんですね
嫉妬って何なのかというと
このもうまあパーリ語でイッサーというんですね
これは精神の衣装替えなんですね
衣替えなんですね 基本的に生命は貪瞋痴の衝動で生きているんですね
これはずっと言っていることだからね
我々の本能としての衝動は貪瞋痴なんですね
その中で怒りは多数の顔を持っているんです
貪瞋痴といったら三つだけでしょ
その三つの中で真ん中にある怒り
この怒りはいろんな顔を持っているんですね
だから この前も昔 講演で説明してしまったからね
1500の煩悩あるんだよと
1500の煩悩と言ったって貪瞋痴なんですね
だから貪瞋痴があらゆる顔を持っているんだということなんですね
だから そのすべての顔を覚えておいて
すぐ発見しなくちゃいけないんですね
これは仏教の真理のテスト方法なんですね
わざわざこの人間に 1510の煩悩を教えたって面倒くさいやとか
そんなたくさんリストを覚えられないんでしょうとかね
そんな暇がないよと思う可能性もあります
しかし 各個人にとってどんな形で貪瞋痴が現れたのかということが大事なことなんですね
例えば 前 今ちょっと話始める前に私は例を出したでしょ
この声がきれいなお坊さんだから
もう信者さんがその人でよくしゃべる
あるいはちょっとしゃべったら
その人の顔を見て さらにさらに質問したりする
ということは 一般人がきれいな声の方に寄ってしまうということは当たり前
当然なことで そこで一人の隣のお坊さんの心の中に嫉妬が生まれてくる可能性はありますが
本人がそれを発見しないんですね
だから 人を教えてあげているのではないかと
人に道徳を教えてあげているのではないか
私はその人のことを心配しているのではないかという
この心配の顔をして よく仏教を知っている顔をして
よくもう しっかりと正しく修行することが良いことやという
この智慧の顔をして嫉妬が現れるんですね
だから この変性をよく理解していないと
貪瞋痴が変性するんですね
だからこのたくさん千五百十の煩悩があるんだ
だから説かれているんですね
それを全部覚えていて
この変性 煩悩が変性する仕方もね
それも覚えておけば 自分の心の中にある汚れを発見できます
主に怒りドースですね
イッサ嫉妬ですね それから物惜しみ
マッチャリエ それから後悔
クックーです だから怒りがこの四種類の顔を持っているんです
同じ怒りなんですよ 突然変身して
嫉妬になったり 後悔になったり
物惜しみになったりするんです
だから今日はまあ特にあえて嫉妬の説明しなくてもいいと思います
やめましょうか こういうのは
まあただの怒りの話ですから
怒りについてはもう終わっ
喋って終わりましたからね
なので怒らないことの通ではそこら辺は書いてあると思います
その場の状況に合わせて怒りは衣装替えします
だからその場によって怒りがなんか衣装替えして別な役柄に変わってくるんで
だからこの役柄に騙されるんじゃなくて
やっぱり王の衣装を着て
やっぱり王様やと思うんじゃなくてね
やっぱり王に化けているんだと
本人はこの人やと いうふうに理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから嫉妬っていうのは怒りが化けたんですね
だから これはどうやって理解するかと
このどうやってこれを発見するかと
この反抗的な態度 これは怒りであろうか
嫉妬であろうか 後悔であろうか
物惜しみであろうか 反抗的態度があるんですね
この反抗的態度っていうのは
怒りの本心なんですね
自分に状況 環境 人々は受け入れがたい
合わない 気に入らない
いつでもあの 自分中心にこれ回るんですよ
この自分という軸があって
そこですべての煩悩回るんですね
だから仏教は自我を自我の錯覚なくせと
というと 全部煩悩が落ちちゃうんです
だからこの自分という言葉を強調しなくちゃいけないんですね
この状態がある 自分が置かれている状況
環境が気に入らない あるいは人々気に入らない
その時の反応は怒りです
気に入らんな これは と思ったら
もう正真正銘の怒りですね
嫌だなとかね 思っちゃうと
自分より他人が優れていると感じたら
それも気に入らないでしょう
私はいつら偉いんだと
能力あるんだと思っちゃえば気に入らないんですよ
しかし 偉いと感じたら反抗的な態度は嫉妬ですね
その優れた人に反抗するんですね
この反抗が嫉妬になってくるんです
自分は優位な立場で他にその能力
財産などを必要になる時
物惜しみで反抗する 何か自分の立場が良くて
周りが周りのことを心配してあげなくちゃいけない
後輩のことを心配してあげなくちゃいけない
知らないことを教えてあげなくちゃいけない
アドバイスしてあげなくちゃいけない
あるいは 金やいろんなものをあげなくちゃいけない
その時 物惜しみが割り込んでくるんですね
で 反抗的に なんでこいつらに
私の大事な金あげなくちゃいけないんですかと
なんで私が苦労して勉強したのに
もうこの連中に教えてあげなくちゃいけないんですかとかね
そこで反抗的な態度があって
自分が優位の立場にいるんだけど
分けてわかってあげ 分かち合いたくないんですね
これは物惜しみと仏教で言うんですが
それも怒りがもう化けているんですね
自分の失敗に後悔で反抗する
それから自分自身のことを評価すると
あんまりうまくいってないんだと
いろいろ間違った判断したり
失敗したりすると それに反抗的な態度をとるんですね
それが後悔ということになるんです
そのように怒りが主に 4つに化けるんです
ものすごいまだたくさんなります 4
つだけではないんです
はい もともとのポイントは
この自分こそが偉いという各生命が本能として思っているんです
思っていると言ったら間違いなんですね
その なんでも本能としてその気持ちがあるんです
思うよりも根深くない
根深いんです この前提として自分が偉いという前提で生きている
だから気づかないんですね
自分が唯一偉い存在だと思う
精神的な病 錯覚が原因です
だから結局はすべての生命にはある精神的な病気がありまして
これが自分が唯一存在で偉いんだと
だから自分を何度かいつでも高く評価するんですね
これはなかなか消えませんよ
どんな生命もそんな態度でいるんですね
で これはもう病気で治療しなきゃ治らないんです
で 誰も治療もしない なぜならば気づかないんですね
自分がそんな態度で生きているんだと
我こそ偉いという態度で生きているんだということには全然気づかないんですね
生命は平等だと認めない
差別意識が強い 自我を肯定したい
普通は口先だけですよ
生命は平等だというのは
本心では認めていないんです
いつでも差別しちゃうんです
それから生命は平等と言いながら
とにかく自分の自我を肯定したくて
自分アピールばっかりするんです
日本でも自分探しやらね
アイデンティティやら結構流行ってる単語いっぱいあるでしょうに
また偉いことをやっていると思っているんで
相当勘違いなんですね
無明から起こる妄想によって人はその気になるんですね
だからまず我々には無明があるんですね
真理を知らない ありのままのことを知らない
何も知らないくせに結構妄想するんですね
くせにって単語はよくないんです
知らないんだからこそ人は妄想するんです
お釈迦様は妄想しないんです
必要に応じて論理的な思考はします
その時もこのような思考が現れましたと
それも知っています 妄想するということは
自分が妄想しているんだということも知らないんですね
妄想しなきゃ生きていられないんですね
だから無明がある限り妄想するんですよ
そこで無明があって いっぱい妄想する
無明っていうのは自我
ですね 私が偉いということは
無知だからそう思っているんですね
よくよく見るともう何もないんですよ
すべて無常苦無我ですから
私というこの錯覚だけなんですね
そんなこと知らないでしょうに
ですから 自分がいるんだと言って
それから妄想を始めるんですね
妄想の結果 怒りやら嫉妬やら後悔やら落ち込みやら
いろんなものが出てくるんです
ブッダが説かれた真理を理解すること
実行すること以外 治療方法はありません
だからこれは困ったもんで
世の中何を勉強したっても治療方法はないんです
だから最近まで日本の社会もよかれと思って
アイデンティティ 自分探しをしましょうよとかね
で やっているんだから
若者にね 自分決まった生き方で生きてみなさいよと言って
だらしない連中になってしまっちゃったんですね
仕事もできないし それで今さら仕事を探したっても仕事もないし
まあいいことですね だから仕事がないということは
能力がないということでしょう
若者がこの変な自分探し
存在のしない自分探しに行かないで
まあ能力を向上して もう社会のために貢献することは生きることではないかと思ったならば
若者もいろいろ能力が出てくるでしょうね
能力がどんどん咲いてくると
もう仕事ですよ いくらでも
社会が変わっても 経済状況が変わっても
新しい仕事が現れてくるんです
全然心配することはないんです
だから変なこの自分のアイデンティティという変なものを探しているんだから
これには時間ロスでしょう
だって たとえ話で言えば
人間が自分が自分の尾っぽを探しているような感じでしょうね
探したっても見つかりっこはないでしょうね
だから死ぬまで探さなくちゃいけないんですね
あるはずやと 変な選定してしておけば
だから自我があるんだよといきなり言っちゃうでしょ
宗教の本なんか開けてみてください
まず魂の霊魂の話から始まるんですね
だから この変なヘリクツで
まずあるんだよと言い始めたら
あるとまず証拠を出せということでしょう
科学者ならそうでしょう
計算していくと まあブラックホールみたいな何かあるみたいやと
これ見えないんだからわからないんだから
計算上成り立つんだから
じゃあわからないところやと言ってブラックホールにしましょうよと
ホールというのは穴ですからね
それから調べると これは穴じゃないんです
最近新しいブラックホールを見つかったという記事があったんですけど
あの太陽はもう 23ミリオン太陽入られますと
ちょっと大きいんですね
太陽の大きさのものは 23ミリオン
ミリオンってどれぐらい？え？ 2,300万でしたっけ？ぐらい入っても減っちゃうという
だからこう穴じゃないんです
結局は まあよくわからないも
しかし まあデータを探して調べてあるだろうというのは普通でしょう
データはないんだけど
ありますと それからそれについて喋るっていうのはあまりにも変なんですよ
証拠はないんだけど 自我がありますよと
証拠がないんだけど 神様がいるんだよと言って
それからもうサンタクロースにも
まあ思い立ったところで腹が立ちますよ
こんなに馬鹿どもが世の中でいるのかいと
わざわざ子供たちに叩くんでしょ？サンタクロースがいるんだぞとかね
はい 嫉妬のことは昔から知っていることですね
昔からもう悪い性格の一つとして発見してあったんですね
嫉妬は発見しているんです
昔からも知っているのに
治らない理由は何ですかね
あるとは発見してますよ
しかし 治す方法がないんですね
あれ 自我の問題なんですよ
みんな頭が悪いんです
貪瞋痴もその他の煩悩も精神の心の本能です
この落下しない理由は
我々の本能は貪瞋痴です
生命の本能は 本能的な問題を解決するためには
抜本的な改革が必要です
本能を直すんだからね
相当大変ですよ あの医学でやっている遺伝子改変研究みたいな大変なもとなんですよ
人間のゲノムまで変え替えて治療するんだよとか言ったら
これは相当大変な仕事になるんですね
だから誰もやってない
ただ感情で喋ってるだけ
それは土台は壊せないんですね
だから我々は貪瞋痴という土台で生きているんですね
これは壊せないんですよ
はい 立ってる土台壊しましょうよと
それはできるわけないんですね
だから嫉妬を発見しましたけど
嫉妬しないようにしますよと言ったっても
あれ どうすればいいのかいと
出てこないんです それで結局はやっぱりしょうがないと
嫉妬せざるを得ないという結論に達するんです
貪瞋痴は精神の基礎として働く
枝に座ってその枝を伐採することはできませんでしょ
枝にドカンと座って この枝を伐採する
これはかなりやばいんですよ
ですから 貪瞋痴に基づいて貪瞋痴の衝動で生きていて
貪瞋痴が本能にして貪瞋痴から出てくる嫉妬などなどをなくそうと思っても
これはありえないんです
ですから 私は他の宗教の事方々が言っていることでも
いろいろたまたまちらちらと読んだりするんですけど
誰でも煩悩は正当化するんです
なくせると思ってないんです
例えば 永遠の天国あるんだそうっていうのは
もうむちゃくちゃ自我を正当化することですよ
この人々より俺が特別でかったそうという
えらい優越好きぶれなるんですよ
神様を信仰する 日本でも神様を信仰する人々は私たちのことをすごく軽視するんです
あ そうですかと 私はね
幼稚園の時でも洗礼を受けているんだよという偉そうなことを言うんですね
こちらの気持ちは知らないんですね
よくも人間でいるんだよと
あんなアホなこと情けないんですよ
しかし このやっぱりその人々は
じゃあもう誰かにボランティアでもしましょうとかね
なんとかはするんだけど
煩悩をなくそうっていうことはないんですね
どこかのね あの不幸になっている人を助けたっても
あれは自分たちの宗教から見れば違反でしょうね
だから神の失敗を直しているんだからね
あのマッキントッシュのジョブスさんがキリスト教をやめたのは同じ理由だそうで
若い時 子供の頃ね なんとかこのアップかどうかの写真を持ってきて
なんか自分にキリスト教の先生に質問を出しちゃってね
それっきりでお前の日曜学校には来ないぞと
と書いたみたいです だから神はすべて前もって知ってますか？と聞いたら
知ってます 言ったら ものすごい貧困の写真 2つ
子供の 2つ見せて 私はこの子供二人で誰かを養子にするのかと
神が知ってますかと それはもう答えられなくてね
それで喧嘩になったということで
本に書いてありますけど
まあどうかはわからないのですから
放っておきましょう とにかく
全知全能の神が作った世界で
なんで不幸があるんですか？なんで差別があるんですかね？なんでいろんな苦しんでいる人々がたくさんいるんですかね
そうすると言うんですよ
あなた方にこの修行 修行ではなくて
あなた方にもこの愛を試すチャンスやと
こちらが愛を試すのはいいんだけど
向こう側はどうですかね
残酷でしょ 俺の愛を試すために
一人の人間が一生障害を持って人間らしい生活できないということは
ひどい話でしょうに だから結局はこのちょこちょこっと
まあ確かにいいことしますよ
他の宗教の方々も でも煩悩をなくすとかね
心清らかにするということは管轄外なんですね
そこで神に認められて
もう自我を肯定するということになるんですね
ヒンドゥー教でも同じで
日本にはもうたくさん宗教ありますからね
インドには勝ってますよ
皆様は 本当に宗教のむちゃくちゃ
もう宗教の呪回というかね
これインドやと言ってきたんですけど
やっぱり日本の方が勝ってると思いますよ
あるわあるわあるわ もういろんな宗教
またそれカビのようにもう新しいもの
新しいもの 次から次へと現れてくるんだからね
だからどんなそうやって宗教カビが出ても
誰一人もこの心清らかにする
その方法 清らかにするべきか全然知らん
日本ですからね 先祖供養しなさいよと
そればっかりいるんです
言ってるんですね なんか先祖成仏供養という変なものも作ったりして
もう金取るんですね ある宗教が
だからこちらもこちらでもう脳細胞もうもう取り上げられたんだから
生まれる時はね だから信じるんですね
やっぱり自分のひいひいひいひいおじいちゃんが成仏できないんだから
自分が今不幸だよと だから成仏させてあげなくちゃいけないんだと言って
じゃあもうそれはあまりもひいひいひいおじいちゃんだからね
それ分  10万  10万  10万
10万上がっちゃうんですね
ある人は本当に私に聞いたんですね
これはあの 自分の自分の男性が聞いたんですけど
彼女はこういうことで
この先祖供養しようとしているんですけど
かなり金額もかかりますからと
で もうどうします？じゃあいい加減やめなさいよと
あなた方の親戚でね 死んでからもあなた方を恨むやつだったらね
そんなちっぽけな供養したってもね
性格直らないんだよと
生きていたってもそうでしょう
放っておけと そんなにも金があるんだったら
なんであの東北の方なんて行ってね
寄付しないんですかと
だからもうどこかで行ってお金を寄付して
あるいは寄付したくなかったら
自分で何か持っていって
そこを助けてあげて それで回向してくださいと
むちゃくちゃ金のあるところにね
さらに金あげるんじゃなくてと
まあ言ったんですけど
やらないでしょうね ですから
この今日説明しているポイントは
あの嫉妬 欲ないとね どんな宗教も言ってますよ
しかし なくす方法はないんですね
心の汚れなくす方法は誰も説いてないんです
だからヒンドゥー教でもね
やっぱり心の汚れを落として
もう煩悩一になりましたよと言うんだけど
あれ 自我肯定するんですね
私が神と一緒に一体になるんだよということだから
相当の自我でしょ だからこの微妙な思考パターンでわかりますよ
やっぱりダメや こりゃと
生存欲と自我愛着のある生命は
弱者を壊して生き続けるんですね
我々は生きているということは
まあどうかで いつでも弱者を壊していじめて生きていることなんですよ
これはもうなかなか治らないんです
だって魚食べてるでしょ
チキン食べてるでしょ
弱者でしょ もし鶏さんがね
ゾウぐらい体格になったらどうするんですかね
追っかけてきたらどうしようもないでしょうね
自分が食べられますからね
壊せない 潰せない弱者に対して
嫉妬または恐怖感を抱く
ですよ これ漢字で合ってます
で そこで弱者ならもう潰します
イワシなら取って丸焼きにして食べます
ではサメなら まあ怯えて逃げることですよ
これってどんな生命にもやり方なんです
そこでサメなら恐怖感を感じる
もうサバンナに行ったんで
行って もうもうもう勝手に自我を張って散歩をしたところで
ライオンを見つけたら
もうものすごく怖くなって恐怖感を感じる
なぜならば ライオンが強者で人間が弱者なんです
では 人間同士でどうなるんですかね
人間同士でも強者と弱者が弱者がいるでしょ
それで弱者ならバカにするわ
いじめるわ けなすわ こき使うするわ
キリがないんです 相手が強者だったら
結構くそっと逃げる 怖いと
例えばヤクザに会ったら
できるだけ敬語を使って
それも普段使わないぐらい使おうと思って間違ったりもして
またもうもう怖くなって逃げると
それで会社の仲間で同僚で強者がいたら
そこで嫉妬するんです
なんだあいつはと 同じ年代でこの会社に入ったんではないかと
二人も一緒に なんでこいつだけもう上に上がっちゃって
そこで嫉妬するんですね
これが人間の生きるパターンになっています
はい それでそのポイント終わり
仏教以外誰にもこれ解決策を持ってないんです
これははっきり言わなくちゃいけないんです
仏教といっても 仏教ではなくて
お釈迦様なんですね お釈迦様が持ってます
解決策は お釈迦様を商売にして仏教という宗教を作ったんだから
そちらにはない可能性はいくらでもあります
お釈迦様というのは結構商売にはね
金に 儲かってますね いろんな人はね
悪用して だって日本の新興宗教を作っちゃうと
何かしら仏教に因縁をつけないと
因縁つけないと成り立たないんですね
これはちょっと頭イカれすぎちゃって
我はブッダだそうだよと言ってる連中もいるんですね
これは怒られる 怒られるのはいいんだけど
ちょっと怒りすぎなんですね
我こそブッダに生まれ変わりやと言ったら
もう話にならないんですね
今まで新興宗教はまあまあ仏教だという風に言っていてね
一応自分が如来になりやがっちゃいますよ
私が如来だ 私はブッダだとかね
よくそこまで病気になるっていうことは面白いでしょ
でもあれ 金が儲かるんだからね
並の金じゃないでしょ
あんな簡単で楽々で 何百億ですからね
金を稼ぐ単位も億になってるんです
そういうことだから  だからといってブッダは関係ないんですよ
ブッダは人類に真理を語ったんです
幸福の道を語ったんです
商売繁盛を語ってないんです
そこで私が言いたいポイントは
ブッダの教えにお釈迦様の教えには
心清らかにする方法はちゃんとあります
それ以外は残念ながらないと
ないっていうのは 批判的に言うんじゃなくて
こういうこの考え方では見つかりっこはないやということなんですね
だから 例えば水はどれぐらいあるのか知りたくて
テープを持って測っても測っても意味がないでしょうに
水は長さで測るものじゃないんだからね
誰かさんが定規を持ってきて
じゃあ測ってあげるぞと
これはもうダメですよ
だからこの方法論の問題なんですね
嫉妬は発見していますよ
嫉妬も怒りもちゃんと発見しています
発見しただけ あの いくつかの病気があるでしょ
たまに 100万人  200万人に一人にかかるとかね
お医者さんたちがそういう病気を発見しています
どんなカラクリで病気になるのかと知ってますけど
治療はないんです イギリスのある女性がね
なんか足がいつでも成長するんで
伸びるわ 伸びるわ 伸びるわ
だから今は自分でももう運べない状態になって
そこでまた何か問題が起きちゃって
壊死状態になって足一本切っちゃったんですけど
それでその代わりに義足をつけましたけど
義足もこんなもの バカでかいものなんです
だからどうなってるのかと知ってますけど
あの女性では治療はないんです
そんな感じで発見しただけでいいわけじゃないんです
はい 次のポイントは この癖ということで
本能があってもすべていっぺん機能するわけではありません
我々には貪瞋痴の本能がありまして
貪瞋痴は 1510種類の衣裳ができます
変身します だからといって
一人の人間が全部やっているわけじゃないんです
だから嫉妬は誰にもあるんだけど
人類みんな知って嫉妬しているわけじゃないんです
憎しみの能力はみんな持ってますけど
すべての人間が憎しみやってるって
それはないんです 欲はみんなにありますけど
みんな欲に絡んで頭イカれてるというと
それは違いますよ ですから本能としてあるんだけど
機能するのは一部なんですね
状況によって悪い性格が現れるんです
その都度その都度何か変身して現れるんです
だから動物はさえも殺したことがない人でも
もしかするとその状況にはめられたら殺してしまうことはいくらでもありますね
自分が寝ている時 自分の家に泥棒が入ったところで入ったなとわかったら
まあ怯えて隠れる人もいる
それも性格 大変だ 見つかったら殺されるかもしれませんとか
どこかに隠れて押し入れの中でじーっといる可能性もある
あるいはやばい こいつを追い出さなくちゃという風に凶暴になる可能性もある
だからどんな煩悩が活動するのかは
これ以上とそれぞれ人によって違いますね
そこでやばいと思ったら
こいつを追い出さなくちゃと思って
これはなんとかって もう野球バットで持っていた頃で
向こうも包丁を持ってきて持っていると
そうするともう包丁は短いんだから
とにかくバットでぶん殴っちゃうでしょうね
だからぶん殴る場合は
あのほどほどにしましょうってないでしょ
だから力いっぱい殺す気で殴るし
それで殺してしまう可能性もあります
だから そんなもんなんですね
我々の心っていうのは
だから怖いんですよ いろいろ状況
環境によって この千五百の煩悩が適当に自分
私の出番だーって役に合わせて衣装替えしてくるんです
これがいいわけじゃないんです
一度でも嫉妬した 嫉妬したことがない人が
まあ六十八歳になってから嫉妬に悩む可能性
可能性ありますよ 夫婦は仲良く長い間一緒にいたっても
もう男性はだいたい早く衰えちしまいますからね
まあ男の方がなんかもう歩けなくなっちゃって
車椅子になっちゃって
それは奥さんが元気で元気ピンピンで
それであちらしたりこちらへ行ったり
社会に出たり 友達と喋ったり
いろんな活動をしたりして
全然家にいない だから車椅子に座っている男性が今更嫉妬する可能性はありますよ
状況変わったんだから
だから自分が自分の奥さんだから
家にいてほしい 自分のそばにいてほしいというね
それでたら この人あまりにも元気で
もう社会で歩き回ってるんだから
嫉妬する可能性あります
だから ずっと一度も自分の奥さんに対して嫉妬ことがない
なのにある時はもうあり得るんです
そんなのは だから状況によってどんなものが出てくるかっていうことはね
相当これはもうやばいと思った方が一番正しいんです
私自身が相当やばいんだよと
だって どんな感情 どんな気持ちが起き上がってくるかわからない
怒り 嫉妬 落ち込みなどは
やはり繰り返し起こると
心がそれに慣れてしまうんですね
これがとてもとても大変なことで
これ 性格というのはそういうことなんですね
それによってこの性格が成り立ちます
簡単に破壊のあ これ 悪循環が現れるんですね
だから 例えば自分より強い人を見て嫉妬しちゃったら
もう慣れちゃったんです
嫉妬に もう一人 自分より強い人を見たら
またその人に嫉妬してしまっちゃいます
だから 同じ感情を繰り返し起こると
結構プロになっちゃいます
だから 芸能世界ででも
似た役柄をいろんなドラマでやっちゃうと
もうその人には敵わないでしょう
例えば 映画 ドラマなどで悪役に決まってる俳優さんも女優さんもいるでしょ
どんなドラマにしたっても
悪役をお願いするんですね
本人は他の役もできますけども
金も欲しいしね だからワンパターンの役やるんですけど
やがてとてもとても上手な腕のいい役者になってしまいます
いとも簡単に悪役をやってみせると
だから 主役よりも時々
この悪役の方があまりにもインパクト強い場合もありますよ
だからそのことで同じことなんです
それ 心ですよ 同じことを繰り返しちゃうと
もう慣れたもんなんですね
ですから ある環境で起こってしまったら
また似た環境ですぐ起こるということにプログラムされちゃいます
脳っていうのは もう心っていうのはそうやって簡単にプログラムしてしまいます
ただ 寒くなったら いやな寒さはと思ったら
寒いと思うたびに もう嫌な気分になるんです
時々寒くないのに寒いだろうと思って
もうブーブーと文句を言うんです
時々私は温度計を見てくださいと言いたくなるぐらいですよ
私は寒がりだからとか何とかって
25度なんですけど そこまでもう頭がおかしくなってしまいます
ですから この嫉妬の場合も
嫉妬しまったら 知って嫉妬してしまったら慣れちゃいます
それから自動モードで次の場面でも嫉妬する
そうすると自分の性格になる
だから嫉妬するべきものにも
嫉妬してはどうでもいいものにも嫉妬するということになるんです
他のことできなくなるんです
だから これって恐ろしい悪循環なんです
一回起こったら 二回目は簡単に起これます
三回目はもっと強く起こるんです
それから四回目からは起こらずいられなくない
いられない状態になってしまいます
もう怒りそのものになってしまいます
だから これは煩悩の恐ろしいからくり
働きなんですよ ですから
この怒り 嫉妬 憎しみというのは破壊のエネルギーを持ってますよ
だから自己破壊になるんです
一旦壊れかけたら もう
どうしようもない もう最近とてもいい例があるんですよ
あの福島原発 一旦壊れたらもう
どうにもならん メルトダウンじゃなくてメルトスルーになっちゃって
どれぐらい燃料がメルトダウンして下に落ちたかもわからないし
釜はもう穴開けてコンクリートを今溶かしているし
コンクリートも溶かして
もうそのうち地面に入るでしょ
それから水脈やらどこにつなげているかわからないしね
日本は地震国家だから
これなおさら計算難しいし
突然青森が汚染されたとか
大阪の水が汚染された
わからないんですよ 私の話を聞いて余計に心配する必要はないんだけど
一応もうどうわからないんだけど
冷温停止状態になりましたと自慢げに言ったってもね
こんな気休めの言葉はね
だからもう 手を加えられない
見られない 調べられない
我々は 私はいつでも言ってますからね
人間というのは歩いている原子炉だと
よく注意して扱わなかったらどうなるかわからないんだと
だから私たちの心も全くあの原子のウランみたいな感じで
もう連鎖反応で同じことを繰り返して繰り返してやっちゃいます
そこで管理できないんです
貪瞋痴で生きている間は制御不可能なんです
この自己制御ということを教えたのは仏教なんです
だからお釈迦様は未だかつて誰にも発見できなかったことを発見しましたよと
苦行なんかはみんなやってますよ
断食もやってますけど
それでは自己制御にはなりません
はい また世論のところに入ります
嫉妬は良くないという世論に説得力はありません
嫉妬の原因を発見していないからです
嫉妬してはいけませんけど
お母さんも言ったでしょ
皆様にも でもお母さんの言葉には説得力なかったんです
だから皆様はすっと嫉妬しているでしょうに
だからお母さんは嫉妬は良くないとわかってるんだけど
こんな原因で嫉妬しますよということをわかってないんだから
まあ言うのは言うんだけど
まあ我々は聞き流しちゃう
真面目 あ そうですか 今日からじゃあ頑張ります
嫉妬しないようにと一度は思ったことないでしょう
嫉妬されることは怖いんです
本当のところは 嫉妬はしたいんだけど
嫉妬されるのが怖いんです
自分のことを知ってる人っていうのは
嫉妬している人はとんでもない怖いんですよ
何するかわからないんだから
どこで落とし穴を掘るかわからないんですよ
自分がいないところでどんな噂を流せるか
よくわからないんですよ
ものすごい危険なんです
だから私たちはへっちゃらで人のことを嫉妬しますけど
自分が嫉妬されることになっちゃうと
まあ怖くていても立ってもいられなくなっちゃうんです
だから嫉妬は良くないと言うんです
はっきり言えば 汝嫉妬するなかれなんです
みんな言ってるのは 私はではないんです
宗教の本を開けたらそういうことでしょう
汝はなになにするなかれとお前はとないんです
だから神は汝は殺すなかれ
と言ったっても 神やツに聞いてみれば
あれは残酷に人を殺しているでしょう
に これっておかしいんですよ
だから世論というのは
汝はなになにするなかれなんですね
あなた 私のことを放っておけと
言い返し 言い返しするなよと
例えば息子にお父さんが言う
君は人を嫉妬 嫉妬してはいけませんよと
お父さんもお父さんは嫉妬しないの？お父さんも頑張ってお前は何？何様のつもりで
かと怒るんです だから世の中って道徳ってそんなもんなんですね
お前やりなさいと 俺は大丈夫やと
これは道徳じゃないでしょ
だから私の主論は私論は道徳
人に道徳を押し付ける
押し付けることほど非道徳な行為がないんだよと
はい 嫉妬の結果を見て悪いと判断するが
まだなくす方法になってくると曖昧です
だからみんな嫉妬ってえらいやばい
怖いとは知ってます 嫉妬する人が何するかわからない
あの ちょっとジャータカ物語もありましてね
ある男性が結婚して ものすごい金持ちの人がね
で これですごい気に入ってる人と結婚したんですけど
なかなか子供が生まれません
それでものすごい膨大な莫大な金持ちだから
跡継ぎを作らないんです
作らなくてはいけないんですね
そこで当時ですから 奥さんは何人もらっても構わないんです
しかし この男は自分の奥さんのことを気に入っちゃって
もうとにかくまあこいつでよろしいやと
で 思ってるんだけど 親やら親戚やらみんな王様やらね
これで困りますよと あんたはもう財閥で金持ちでね
こんな勝手なことやるともう困りますよと
だから跡継ぎ作りなさいよと
もうもう一人奥さんもらっちゃえと
まあこういうことで まあ奥さんもらいましたけど
まあそこでやっぱり新しい奥さんの方で
まあ妊娠できる可能性ありましたから
やっぱりこの前の奥さんが
この旦那はもうどんどん私よりはこの人のこと好きになるだろうと
これから子供が生まれたらといって
だから何とかしますと言って
何か葉っぱをね ちょっと触れただけ
ものすごく痒くなって
反応を起こす葉っぱがあるんで
自分の国でもいっぱいあります
触れただけでもものすごい痛いんです
あれを取って粉にして
シートの下に 敷いてあったんです
そこでこの彼女がベッドに寝ただけで体中痒くなって腫れて炎症を起こしたりして
そこであちらこちらどうにもならんね
それで大変だといっても
お医者さんとかみんな治療したり
すぐあの薬ありますからね
すぐ何か油って塗ったらもうすぐ治りますけど
みんな医者がこれはって言って治療するんです
治療して じゃあゆっくり休んでくださいと
休んだらどうなるんですかね
また同じこと それでやっとやっぱりこの後ってなんとかなったんですけど
奥さんが前の奥さんがやったっていうことはバレないんですね
だからそれもすごい嫉妬なんですね
彼女は考えてのは この皮膚が痒くてでき物があると
どうしても男は自分の旦那はね
もうあの女はいいやつと結婚やと思っちゃうでしょうねというふうに計算しちゃったんですね
しかし やったことは大変なことやっちゃったんですね
だから物語で それから彼女がその罪でね
もう地獄に落ちたり いろいろストーリーまだありますけど
その辺でやめます そこで我々はこの嫉妬は怖いとは知ってますが
なくす方法は知らないんです
また 欲怒りは成長の発展の起爆剤になるという邪見もあります
結構私にも直接聞かれたこともありますし
やっぱり欲があった方が人間が成長するだろうとかね
ライバル会社に対してものすごい敵意を持って頑張った方が自分の会社が発展するだろうとかね
学校でもライバルがいた方がライバル意識で勉強した方が勉強できるだろうとか
そのとんでもない邪見なんですね
この邪見を持ちながら怒りなくそう
ライバル意識なくそうって成り立たないんです
学校の仲間がライバルだと思っちゃうと
そちらに心配したり 怖がったり
もう恨んだりすることで
脳のエネルギーは全部もう浪費して終わってるんです
勉強するためにも精神力残ってないんです
だから大損なんですけど
平気で言うんですよ 欲があった方がいいとか
結婚したら旦那に嫉妬した方がいいとか
それだったら不倫しないように自分には旦那を管理することはできますとか
逆なんです 旦那のことを嫉妬すると不倫するんです
お前大した男じゃないんだから
もう勝手に言いなさいと言っちゃうと
男ですから 自分を売るために奥さんに一生懸命頑張っちゃいます
だから逆に旦那さんに嫉妬すると
自分というのは結構モテるんだよと思って試してみるんです
外で ではなくて まあ私のことどうも
まあまあ結婚しちゃったんだけど
失敗しましたねとかね
もっといい男がいるのにとかね
まあ大したことないっていう感じでいると
やっぱり自分がアピールしなくちゃいけないんだとと思う場合
可能性は大いにあります
認めてほしいっていうことはどうしてもありますからね
ですから この嫉妬はいい場合もありますよとか
そんな邪見に陥ったらひどい目に遭いますよ
欲があった方が仕事はうまくいくんだよと思ったら
とんでもない邪見なんです
うまくいかないんです
はい そういう風にもう世の中に邪見もありますから
嫉妬をなくす世界じゃないんです
はい これから経典に入ります
イダマナエカッチョイッティワプリソワイッサマナコホーティ
故事 ある人に喋った経典なんです
ある男または女が嫉妬の心で生活します
これは意訳ですけど イッサマナコ
マナコっていうのはもう心はいつでも嫉妬で回転させるというね
パララバサッカラガルーカラマナナワンダナプージャプージャプージャナスイッセティウパディッシャティイッサムバンドゥティ
他人が受ける利益 尊敬
名誉などに対して嫉妬する
嫌な気分になる 嫉妬の関係を持つ
で 省略しましたけど 他人を尊敬されると
他人を褒められると 他人がいろいろ利益をもらうと
もう嫉妬する そこで慣れちゃって
もうその人と嫉妬の関係になるんです
ああ あの人でしたっけ？と言った途端
もう嫉妬ができてくるようになると
ソーテーナカッメーナエワンサマッテーナエワンサマディンネーナ
カーヤッサベーダ パランマラナアッパヤンドゥッガティンヴィニパタンニリヤンウパガッチャティ
その人は嫉妬を優先した生活をして
死後 不幸に堕落した境地に地獄に生まれる
あんま嫉妬したらもう直行行けますからね
で しかし このこっちの経典は私には正しく訳できません
だからそういう意訳にしますけど
あのちょっと嫉妬したことで地獄に落ちるわけじゃないんです
それはお釈迦様もそう気をつけるんです
嫉妬するはするはするはするは
嫉妬が癖になっちゃって
嫉妬が性格になっちゃって
嫉妬から心が離れない状態になった人が直行
たまたまちょこっと嫉妬してしまった
まあ忘れちゃったって
それは大丈夫です それはまあちょっとした一考の罪で
根が出る可能性も出ない可能性もあります
ではなくても 嫉妬好きになることなんですね
だからどんな悪の場合でも
もう繰り返し繰り返しやって
もう性格と一緒になったらもう話にならない
次は必ず地獄に不幸に陥るんです
だからそこら辺はあんまり怖いと思う
まあ怖いと思った方がいいんだけど
あの私もやっぱりある人に嫉妬したことがあるんだ
やばいと思うなくても構わないんです
誰にしたっても 結構いろいろ嫉妬した経験があると思いますよ
それでダメってわけじゃなくて
もう嫉妬ばっかりしやがって
性格そのもの 嫉妬になっちゃって
もう離れないようになってしまったら
もうダメですね 地獄に堕落することなく
衰落です 堕落することなく
人間として生まれたならば
微力の無能の人間になります
もし地獄に落ちないで人間界に生まれたとしましょう
生まれたら何の力もない無能の人間で生まれますよと
他人の利益 尊敬 名誉などに心を痛む
悩む 嫉妬する 嫉妬の性格はこじよ
威力の無能の生命になる道です
で これある人がお釈迦様に聞いたんだよ
お釈迦様 なんで人間様々ですか？と
長寿がいて 短命のいる
美しい人がいて 醜い人がいる
ものすごい迫力のある威力のある偉大なる人間がいて
存在 存在感さえもない
ちっぽけな虫けらみたいな人間もいるんだよ
なんだこりゃと 皆様に同じ質問したら
これ神様がそう決めたでしょ
答えは お釈迦様はそう答えません
明確に説明するんです
人間の心はこのように
このように働くと このような結果になりますよと
その長い経典の １ 行です
これは １ 行というか  2 行ツーセクションですね
偉大なる力にある人に生まれ変われる
全くも力のない無能の人間に生まれる
その 2つは嫉妬するか嫉妬しないか
どちらなんです これは真珠に回にあります
チューラカーミ・バンガスッタというんです
はい これで嫉妬はどんな働きしてくれるのかと勉強しましょう
過去世で嫉妬の癖があったならば
存在感のない無能な人間になるという話です
もうもうわかるでしょう
人間の中でいろいろいるでしょう
今もかわいそうですけど
今更どうすることもできないんで
これは 過去世でもう嫉妬したならば
何の力もなくない ないんです
全然存在 存在感がないんです
あの時々いるでしょ なんかこのたまにこのタレントさんとして選べる人々っていうのは
相当存在存在感があるでしょ
もう舞台に部屋に入る時にはみんな待ち構えてて
キャーって明るくなっちゃって
みんな拍手したり あれ
すごいパワーでしょ まあ世界的なね
有名な人もいるし もう地方的に有名な人もいるし
まあ時々この笑い芸人たちとかね
頑張って頑張ってうまくいかなくて
途中で諦める場合もあるでしょ
あの大した笑いもできないのに
結構売れてレギュラー番組持ってる人々もいるでしょ
やっぱりあれ迫力なんですよ
あの存在感なんです だからカメラマンたちから見れば
もうカメラに写ったら
まあかっこいいというか
なんとなくあの写真的に見れば
まあ気分がいいんですね
カメラマンにとっては
だからそういう人々はレギュラーに選んでしまっちゃう
それはそれは小さい時から無茶金儲かってね
えらい贅沢するでしょ
やっぱりそういう方々は過去世で嫉妬というのはやってないんです
嫉妬しない代わりに人々を助けてあげたり
人々と一緒に仲良くしたりしたんだから
その結果に 今もみんなに喜びを与えてがっぷり儲かってるんです
本当は儲かりたいという気持ちさえもないんです
むちゃくちゃ金が入るだけなんです
ですから ものすごい美しい体を持ったりとかね
で 能力あったりとかね
もうあるいは体がそれほどかっこよくないんだけど
なんかいると明るくて楽しい
雰囲気が明るくするという
このオーラを持ってるんですね
それがなくなるんですよ
まるっきりもうゼロではなくて
マイナスになってしまいますよ
嫉妬すると あの これよく読まない
進行性筋ジストロフィーという病気があります
プログレスマスキュラーディストロフィーというんです
ご存知でしょうね 嫉妬は心を似た状態にさせるんです
あの 誤解しないでください
この PMD は嫉妬の結果じゃないんです
それは別です それは別ですけど
あの肉体がどんどん衰えていくでしょ
だいたい 20歳になってくると
もう生きていられなくなって死んでしまいます
20歳まで生きられるかもわからないんです
治療もないんです そこで心に嫉妬が入ったら
この PMD と同じ状態になっちゃうんです
どんどん心が衰えて衰えて衰えて
もう全くまあ消えてしまう状態になってしまいます
いてもいなくても 誰も気にしない状態になっちゃうんです
あの 皆様の家でも 時々壁に小さな虫たちがいたり
もうちょこちょこっと来てね
蛾が来ていたりとかする場合あるでしょ
あんまり気にしないんですね
そこで人間でありながら自分の立場
そうなったらどうですかね
なんか家の人は まあ虫一匹いるぐらいの態度で
あまり気にしないというね
気にならない 放っておけばいいやという感じで
これってかわいそうでしょ
嫉妬するたびに心の能力が衰えるんです
だからこれ相当怖い 怖いことですよ
嫉妬したら能力低下 また嫉妬したらまた能力低下
もともといくら能力があったっても
もう知ったことじゃないんです
どんどん減って漏れてしまいます
だからすごく弱い やばいんですよ
嫉妬は 私も小さい時からどんな悪さをしたっても
嫉妬だけはしないよと
小さい時から決めていたんです
嫉妬しなくちゃあかん場面に時々あったりはしますよ
で 嫉妬 嫉妬すると こいつに腹が立つか
逆に助けてあげるかと自分で考えるんですね
とんでもない悪いことやってるんだよとかね
私はいえ 助けた方がいいと決めるんです
で 助けてあげたところで
何のこともただで自分の能力が上がっているんです
ですから この 嫉妬すると能力が随分下がっちゃってしまいます
オーラも威力もなくなってしまいます
これから始めたら終われないという病気
もう現象がありますよ
嫉妬には 一旦嫉妬が起きたら
限りなく成長させることが簡単にできます
執着 嫉妬をどんどんどんどん増やすということは至って簡単です
ウイルスみたい 細菌みたいにどんどん繁殖するんです
だって花なんか育てるのは大変でしょ
カビだったらどうですかね
勝手に成長するでしょ
嫉妬はそんなもんです
恐ろしく成長するんです
嫉妬は他人の良いところ
美徳を認めない 我慢できないという暗い気持ちです
嫉妬っていうのは前の定義で出しましたけど
人の美徳をどうかなとかね
思っちゃうんですね その通りだと認めては来ない
認めたくはないんですね
だから嫉妬のおかしいところは
本当は認めているんです
だから嫉妬するんです
だから相当な無知なところなんです
だから文章を書くときは認めたくないと書かなくちゃいかんだけど
あれ 認めすぎちゃって腹が立っているんです
人を自分と比較するんです
相手の美徳は自分より優れていると発見するのです
自分の無能に対する怒りが嫉妬です
こんな流れで怒りが生まれるんです
相手には美徳があって
いや こいつは嫌だなと思っちゃうんだけど
美徳があるともとっくに認めているんですね
それで己の心を見るんですね
あ 俺には何もないんだと
で 怒ってくるんですね
なんで俺だけダメなのか
その怒りが嫉妬というんです
すごいシンプルなプロセスです
平等ですか 生命は同一ではありません
能力は様々です 他の生命を自分と比較すると
自分に優れていない能力はいくらでも無制限に見つかります
これがポイントです 文章的に切られちゃったんですけど
言葉でまとめて言います
自分と違った能力ある人を見て嫉妬するでしょ
そうするといくらでも情報がありますよ
どんな人間見ても 自分と違った能力を持ってるんです
自分持ってない能力は持ってるんです
どんなに生命でも だって生命は平等ですけど
同一じゃないでしょ あのゴキブリには皆様にない能力あるでしょ
だからどうしますかね
ゴキブリは目がなくても環境は知っている
アンテナ持っているんだから
空気の微妙な動きで 空気の微妙な圧力で人間が寄ってくるんだと知っているんです
どこから寄ってくるのも知っているんです
では どこに逃げればいいかと
それまたアンテナでやっちゃいます
だからゴキブリっていうのは結構おしゃれですよ
もう怖くはないという感じたら
あのアンテナを取って綺麗にもう汚れを落とすんです
口できれいに もうきれいにするんですよ
すごいきめ細かい 見てみると
あのもう目に見えないぐらい小さな何かありますから
1個  1個  1個  1個  1個
1個綺麗にするんですね
私はそれを見て あ こいつにとっては大事な部品だからね
よく頑張って綺麗にしているんだ
手入れしているんだよと
その時 ゴキブリを捕まえるなら今がチャンスやと思ったんですけど
あれ あまりにも美しい姿でしたから
放っておいたんです そういうわけで
嫉妬し始めたら いくらでも見えて
あいつも私より偉い この人も私より何か優れて
あの人も私よりということになってしまうんです
だから終わりなくなっちゃうんです
それに嫉妬する癖が現れたら
嫉妬の気持ちは成長するばかりです
だから自分より優れたとかね
見た瞬間で嫉妬する癖がついちゃうと
もうどうにもならん それからは末期状態になるんです
それから嫉妬は楽しくはないんですよ
元気でやってますけどね
精神的 まあディストロフィーは決して楽しくはないんです
だからディストロフィーっていうのは
どんどんどんどん衰えていく
萎んでいくことなんです
これ 肉体の場合もものすごく痛いんですよ
ものすごい痛いんです
仏教はこの精神的ディストピアのことを喋ってますからね
精神的な場合ももっとひどく痛いんです
痛いと言ったら肉体ですけど
もっと暗いんですよ 我慢できないほど暗くなっちゃいます
それで体も壊れてしまいます
壊れてしまいます だから精神的ディストピアだから
嫉妬する人の場合は体が成長しないんです
これ逆効果でね 心は体に影響を与えて成長しないことにするんです
成長しないとかっこいいでしょ
違うんだと 衰えるんです
あの年がわからない人は徳が高いんです
80歳なんですけど えっと思っちゃう人々は結構徳が高いんです
若さを若さでいられることはね
いわゆるオーラがあって
それと違って年寄りに見えるんです
あなた何歳？って言ったら
あの 21歳ですけど あら
50歳と思った ということなんです
だから精神ディストピアで体
体も成長しないんだけど
衰えちゃうんですね だから嫉妬の人は体見たってわかりますよ
早く老けてます 老けるの早いんだったらね
あの 必ず嫉妬わけじゃないんですよ
我々も結構年寄り老けてしまう場合ありますよ
いろんなストレス溜まったとしてね
もう仕事でいろんな問題があったりして
そういういろんな精神的な圧迫感で
あの 早く老けることもありますけど
これも一つの原因なんです
あの 私の話を受けて勝手に人を判断しないでください
こんなの素人にできるわけじゃないんです
あの 相当な能力が必要です
あなたはこの原因でこうなってるんだよっていうのはね
一応 あの そういうことですと理解した方がいいんですね
決して楽しくはないんです
嫉妬の対象になった相手がどんどん成長するが
自分が衰えていくんです
例えば 田中さんに対して嫉妬したら
みるみるうちに田中さんがうまくいってるんです
自分がどんどん衰えていくんです
さらに悔しいでしょ だから嫉妬された方がいいではないんです
それはちょっと計算違いなんです
田中さんのことを嫉妬しました
しかし 田中さんが普通に毎日頑張ってるだけです
特別に嫉妬されて成長したわけじゃないんです
田中さんが普通に頑張ってるんです
しかし 嫉妬した この人は何か名前がないとね
次郎にでもしましょうか
まあ次郎 次郎さんが嫉妬しました
次郎さんが嫉妬した時点で小さくなっちゃったんです
また比較してみると あ
向こうはプラス3で 私はプラス2でしたけど
今プラス1やと それで差が大きいでしょ
さらに嫉妬するんですね
それでプラス1はマイナス1になっちゃうんです
だからこちらが減っていくだけなんです
だからこちら減ると差がどうしても大きくなるでしょ
だから嫉妬された そのおかげで成長したっていうことじゃないんです
嫉妬された人は知らなかったながら
普通に生きています だから普通の成長はあります
さらに 嫉妬も憎しみも恨みも怒りも増幅するのです
これで嫉妬する人にとっては
この仲間が応援に来るんです
すごい強力 仲間の応援団があるんです
応援じゃなくて協力体なんですね
嫉妬する人に怒りが寄ってきて
もの徹底的に協力してやります
恨みが出てきて 徹底的にサポートします
で もう何でもかんでもたくさんなります
あの まあたくさんありますけど
まあそこら辺でやめます
思い出しちゃうとキリがないんです
だから一旦嫉妬を始めたら
この怒り関係の大量のエネルギーがサポートに協力に行くんです
応援というよりも 皆 自分から離れていくんです
それが最終的な結果 嫉妬する人が最初はちょこっと嫉妬しただけで
どんどん怒りも出てきて
どんどん憎しみも出てきて
どんどん落ち込んだりもして
どんどん引きこもりになっちゃって
どんどん顔色も悪くなっちゃって
能力も減って 人に怒られるようにもなっちゃって暗くなるでしょ
あのオーラが消えちゃうでしょ
オーラが消えて暗くなって
なんか臭くなっていくんですね
精神的に 精神的に似合うんですね
それでみんなそこそこそこうと逃げていくんです
近寄れないんです あの花
世界で 1種類の花があって
花大きいんです これぐらいね
なんとか花ですね あれは
あの花の香りはね あの人間とか死んで 1週間ぐらい経ったとかね
動物死んで 1週間  2週間経ったら
ものすごい臭い ひどい臭いでしょ
あの あの香りです だって花だったら香りでしょ
あのどこかで日本のどこかの植物園で 1本
あの  15年  20年ぶりに 1本しか咲きませんからね
咲いたんだけど 大体 1 日でもう 2 日でなくなります
大きい花ですけど あのこんにゃくですね
あれは えっ？えっ？何？ラフレシア
まあ私から見ればあれはこんにゃくやと
あの自分の国でもその植物はありますけど
芋はもう食べられますよと
だから花咲く前に取らないと
で 花はそう簡単に咲きませんよ
まあ土の中でね あの芋がね
20年くらい待ち構えてないと
そうなってくると あれはあまりにもでっかくて食べられません
日本でもこんにゃくっての
小さい時 柔らかいと取ります
まあ なんで余計な話するんですかね
時間もないし で だからこの嫉妬すると
あの花みたいに 花は花ですけど
誰も近寄りたくはないんです
あの吐き気がするんだからね
あの 本当に匂い嗅いだら意識がなくなって倒れますよ
だからみんな逃げるんです
だから まあ大いに嫉妬することですよ
結構いい香りがもう放つようになります
で あの花はもう花は賢いんだから
なんでかというと この
あの あの青いハエとかいるんですね
腐ったものに飛ぶ だから一生懸命ハエを呼んでいるんですね
ハエを呼び寄せて受粉してもらっちゃいます
そのためですけど しかし
蝶々なんか来るなよと
メス蜂は来るなよと っていうことです
だから我々も嫉妬するということは
蝶々のような人間は出てこないでくださいということなんです
役に立つ美しい性格の良い頭の良い人間はみんな出て行ってくださいと
汚い連中だったらどうぞ来てくださいと
いうことになるんです
煙たがられるんですね
嫉妬される 嫉妬する人は当然煙たがられます
はい 嫉妬の危険性 嫉妬は恐ろしい精神病気です
心の成長をストップするので
仏教は軽く見ない心の汚れです
あの成長はガクンとストップさせちゃって
それから衰えちゃいますからね
冗談じゃないんですよ
怒りよりはかなりやばいんです
自分をたと比較すると
慢 マーナという煩悩も起きますが
嫉妬ほど破壊力はないんです
あの嫉妬っていうのは比較するんだからでしょ
でも 人と比較すると慢も出てきます
あの人は私より偉くてよかったねとかね
やっぱり私はダメだなとか思う
あれは慢ですよ  私はダメだなと思っても嫉妬していないんです
あるいはこの連中よりは私の方がもうかっこいいやと思っちゃうと慢ですね
嫉妬じゃないんです ですから
慢も他人と比較して生まれますが
慢の怖さと嫉妬の怖さは桁違いです
嫉妬の方が怖いんです
優れた人と等しいようになろうと努力するならば
成長する可能性もあります
例えば 誰かと自分を比較しちゃって
ああ あの人は美徳はいっぱいあって
俺がなんだこれ 俺はダメだなとかね
そうすると嫉妬しないで
あ 黙っていられません
俺もあの人と同じくならなくちゃとかね
で 傲慢で考えるでしょ
傲慢と言ったって高慢で考えるでしょ
うまくいく可能性あります
それから頑張れば それから勉強したり
いろんな能力を上げたり
修行したり 頑張ればもう等しくなってしまいます
ですから 慢は使い方によって悪くなったり良くなったりしますけど
嫉妬にはそんなことはできない
ダメです 嫉妬は高濃度の核廃棄物のようなものです
何か使う道ありますかと
ないんです 嫉妬っていうのは高濃度の核廃棄物やと思ってください
使い道はないんです 慢っていうのはやばいんだけど
まあなんとかバイねと使えます
はい これからこの今日のムディタ
ちょっと休憩して始まりましょうか
はい では2部始まります
今日のテーマの 2番目にムディタということですからね
これは嫉妬の解毒剤 で
これが誰でも嫉妬がありますよ
ただ 嫉妬の性格になってないだけでね
朝から晩まで嫉妬をやってるわけじゃないだけですけど
この解毒剤を使わなくちゃいけないんです
ムディタ喜の実践は嫉妬に対して特効薬です
仏教の他の実践方法も有効ですが
心理的に喜は嫉妬の反対です
あのブッダのところでは
どんな実践方法でも嫉妬がなくなりますよ
心は軽らかになり 別にそんなに気を付けることなくても
普通はもう大体嫉妬は大丈夫です
仏教徒であるならば 慈悲の瞑想したっても
呼吸瞑想したっても あるいは瞑想はしないで
ただ五戒守っていたってもね
で まあ大体は嫉妬はなくなりますけど
しかしこのムディタっていうのは
ちょっと薬が違います
この正反対のものなんです
嫉妬の だからカチッとはめてなくなるんです
そこは違うところです
しかし 嫉妬漬けの人には実践できないというケースもあります
嫉妬ばっかりずっとやっていて
この末期状態になってくると
その人々にはこのムディタの実践はもう無理だと思います
この能力はなくなっているんです
あまりにも破壊的で そういう人にはもう私たちに聞けば
別な別な方法は教えますけど
特効薬にはならないんですね
かなり時間がかかります
それほど激しくない嫉妬だったら
特効薬でカシャっともう終了することはできます
嫉妬は末期になる前に初期段階で実践した方が良いです
だから嫉妬とがんと同じである
筋ジストロフィーと同じですよ
危ないんですよ ジストロフィーになったら
だからそこになる前に
まあちょこちょこ嫉妬するとかね
そんなところで始めた方がかなり効き目があるんです
はい ムディタの話に入ります
基本的には自分が喜びを感じる訓練です
これ覚えておいてください
喜び感じる訓練です だからあの
怒るなよとか言ったところで
みんないろいろセミナーやったり
アンガーマネジメントとかやったりとかね
もうアメリカでもやってるみたいですけどね
まあそれからこれもそういうふうに信奉支援でもやった方がいいんじゃないかなと
喜びを感じる信奉支援とかね
はい 今日初めて あの あまりあの注釈書には仏典にもそれほど出てないし
実践法はよく知られていないんです
じゃあ今日初めてやり方ご説明します
金がある 家族が家族は楽しい
出世できたなどでも喜びは感じられますね
でもわかりますね 合格しましたとかね
うちの子は大学合格しました
喜び 楽しいでしょ そう
それなんです うん そんな難しいことじゃないんです
旦那の給料は 2 万上げました
上がりましたとかね 言うと奥さんはまあ微妙に
あ よかったと でも課長部長などに昇格したら結構気分がいいでしょ
で そういう風にこの喜ぶのはいくらでもありますよ
しかし 心は清らかになる
成長する保証はありません
旦那さんが会社の出世は早いんだよとかね
今はもうどんどんどんどん課長になって
もうもう部長にもなって
もういろいろなって 今アメリカ
ニューヨークで全部会社任されてますよとかね
喜びますけど 奥さんの性格清らかになるという保証がないでしょ
それで 奥さんがどんどん気持ち悪い人間になり変わってるから
金な無駄遣いするわとかね
もう見栄張るわとかね
まあ子供たちも教育もダメにするわとかね
もういろいろある可能性は保証はないんですね
喜びは喜びです さらに
財産 名誉などは無常なので
亡くなったら喜びが悲しみに変わります
そんなものは喜んじゃっても
例えばニューヨークのオフィスを任されたと思ったっても
会社がダメになったところで
もう取り戻されて 普通の机で仕事する羽目になったりもしますね
それはわからないんですよ
ですから そういうことで喜ぶのはいいんだけど
問題は二つ 心清らかになる保証はない
それから こんなことに引っかかって変わったらどうするのかと
とんでもなく落ち込んでしまいますね
安らぎは安定しないんです
だから 旦那さんの出世が早いと喜んだっても
安定して安らぎじゃないんですね
子供はもう大学はもう合格しましたと
入学はと 楽しいんだけど
安定して安らぎじゃないんです
大学に入ってから何やってるのかどうかね
また心配になってくるんです
時々真面目に勉強して
高校生でね しっかり大学に入って途中でやめるというケース
いくらでもあるでしょ
授業に行かない 親にも言わない
そうするといい大学に合格してお母さんが喜んじゃったんだけど
あの喜びは安定していないんですね
はい モリターンのと タイトルを作るのは面倒くさくなっちゃって
1 2 3 4 にしたんです
一応いろいろ項目別に説明はしているんです
お釈迦様は喜びの対象として
自分以外の生命を選ぶことを推薦なされたんですね
金があって楽しいな それは瞑想にならないんです
だから自分以外の生命を選んでくださいと
これよく聞いて勉強してください
もうないんですよ テキスト読んでもパーリ語のテキストを読んでも見つからないんです
まずは自分という生命は
自分の喜びを感じる 経験するんです
自分の生命だから 自分も喜びを感じたことはあるでしょうね
そこはちょっと思い出して経験してみるんです
あの楽しみはどうかね
それから他人を観察して喜びが生まれるようにするんです
それからポイントなんですね
人を観察して その人の喜びなんですけど
これは自分も感じてみるんです
あの悪いところではみんなやってるでしょ
映画を見て 舞台を見て
インチキ泣きやってるでしょ
みんな泣いてるんですね
よくわからないんですよ
みんな映画を見て涙ポロポロとかね
あれインチキですからね
全部 私もストーリーで言ってるメッセージが立派だったらすごいなと思いますけどね
誰が中で泣いたってもね
この野郎と という感じ
全然気にもしない 逆に欲も
まあやっぱり仕事だからね
よく訓練してるんだとかね
よく訓練して修行してるんだとかね
そういう人の能力を褒めますけど
皆さんみたいに幻覚に入り込まないんです
まあこの野郎と思うことはないんだけど
あの幻覚に入らないんです
この俳優さんの この女優さんの能力はすごいものだと
本物のようにやってるんだと
本物じゃないんだけど
だからもう私たちもこの間違った世界で
例えばもう最後には全部何て言いますか
ハッピーエンドになるでしょ
それでみんな喜んじゃって
で 機能は同じ 心理学的に機能は同じなんですね
自分と全然関係ないんですけど
自分がそこであのインスピレーションを受けて
心を喜びを感じるんですね
コンピューター用語ではエミュレーションなんですね
はい これよく気をつけてください
簡単ですよ もう誰でもいいんだから
なんか喜んでる人と楽しいみたいな
とかね どんな気分かなとかね
自分もそこを感じてみるんです
もう楽しいだろうね あの人は
とかね まあ例えばまあ私もね
たまに まあ例えばどこかで行くと
まあ高級レストランがあったり
ちょこちょこっと目で片目で見るんです
いろいろ欲しいんだからじゃなくて
私はいつでも勉強してますからね
そこをデータ取らないと
だって出家で在家の方々としゃべれないでしょ
在家の情報を知らないと
だからカラスみたいな感じで
外からちょっと覗いてみて
まあすぐそこを全部皆様より理解するんですよ
このもうこれできるんだからね
そこで誰かさんがもうね
キャンドルをあって キャンドルをさして
これから花を食べて ここでもう男女がね
向かい合って座って ワインもあって
結構楽しい気分でしょうねとかね
雰囲気でとかね そこはその楽しみを
なるほど そういう楽しいだろうと
と感じられますよ ただで
ただはポイントなんです
他人を観察するとき 喜びを感じるという色眼鏡をつけて見るんですよ
もっと俗っぽい言葉で言えば
色眼鏡をつけてくださいと
色眼鏡は悪いと言われているでしょ
いい喜びを感じる色眼鏡
だから喜びのデータしか入らないんです
どんな生命を見ても その人はいろんな気持ち持ってますけど
例えば 若い男女がもう高級レストランでね
もう美味しくディナーをやっているかもしれませんけど
男の見たら相当経済的には無理をしているなとかね
そこを感じちゃうと喜びじゃないでしょ
だから色眼鏡をつけて
そこはカットして あ あの二人が相当楽しい
楽しいだろうなとかね
それだけ心に入れるんです
モニターのさん 要するに心にあえてバイアスをつけるんです
心にあるバイアスをつけてやった方がいいんです
これ簡単です なぜならば
我々はいつでもバイアスを持ってるんですよ
あの ありのままに物事を見ないんです
ですから バイアスで主観で物事を見る
もう能力 もうとっくにあるんです
とんでもない能力なんですけど
それをうまく使えばいいんです
喜びだけ見られるようにバイアスをつけちゃうんです
人と喋ると あんたにとって何か面白いの？今日はとかね
今日何か面白かったことあるの？とかね
そればっかり行く あの
面白いことじゃなくて
今日は いえ それはいいんですけど
何か面白いものないものかと
そのバイアスで調べてみるんです
大変なことになったな
それはあまり興味ないんだけど
俗世間も狭い見方だと思うでしょ
これは こんな風に人間見ると
あなたの見方が狭いだろう
人間楽しいばっかりじゃないでしょうと偉そうなことを言うでしょう
人間って大変だろうと
幸福三昧じゃないでしょうと
一切のバイアスをなくして
ありのままに観察する仕方を説く仏教に矛盾するのではないかとも思われますね
仏教は一切バイアスをなくして
客観的にありのままに観察したら悟りますよと言っているんですね
それだったら これが仏教には矛盾でしょ
この話は だから皆様は議論する前に私は議論を出したいんですと言ったんです
しかし これは 見解は生命の法則に沿った正しい見解なんです
でも残念です 生命が生き続ける法則があるんです
その法則の中にある法則の一つなんです
誰でも喜びを目指して
喜ぶために 楽しむために頑張っているんです
だからみんな期待することなんです
みんな目的にしていることなの
生きる時は だから別にそれ色眼鏡でそれ他のことを遮断して見たっても
ありのままの見ないってはないんですよ
それも一つ ありのままの見方なんです
あえて育てる見方なので
正見ではない これは八正道の正見ではないんです
八正道の正思惟に属しています
これ あえてやることだからね
あえて色眼鏡かけて どんなことかなと見るんですね
で ですから これ正思惟に入ります
ですから 八正道の一部です
喜びを感じると生命は成長しますよ
落ち込んだよりは喜んだ方がいいんじゃない？成長します
能力は向上します 才能は発揮します
世の中の激しい変動に動揺しないで対応できるようになります
落ち込まないでしょ だから何か変なことがあってもね
地震が起きちゃってもね
もう対応できる能力があるんです
落ち込んだらもうとんでもないんですよ
だから これはもう生命の基本的な法則であって
やった方がいいんですよ
喜びを感じる訓練をしたら
もうどんどん能力が上がる
どんどん成長する どんどん才能を発揮する
で またムディタのです
体も心も健康になります
当たり前です 心がもういつでも喜んで楽しいんだったら
体も健康的になります
落ち着いてやれますよ
興奮しないで落ち着いてやれます
他人に好かれます あの
あの花と違うんです 香りが出してるんだからね
他人に好かれます 自分に逆らう人
ライバルがなくなります
今までいたならば 自分に逆らってみようかとか
ライバル的ないろんなことをやっている人がいたってもなくなります
って言ったら死んじゃうんでしょうね
そうなってほしいと思っているかもしれません
死ぬわけじゃなくて その人々の気持ちが変わります
あの人には逆らえないんだよと
たくさんの人々に囲まれて生活することになりますが
それはストレスにも苦痛にもなりません
皆様も結構人々と囲まれて生活しているでしょ
結構ストレスたまりますね
結構緊張したりするしね
これがもうあの花に蝶々が勝手に来て
ちょこちょこっと持っていくと
別に花は何もする必要ないんです
例えばね 美味しい果物にいっぱい実っている
渋柿じゃなくて甘い柿がある
もう柿の木があったりしましょうね
鳥たちが来てちょこっと食べたり
まあ猿も来たら食べたりとかね
別に木がストレス溜まっちゃってどうしようないでしょうに
気にしてみれば食べていった方がいいでしょうに
美味しい実をいっぱい実っているんだから
どうぞどうぞ食べていってくださいという気分でいるんですよ
皆様もそのような人間になるんですよ
たくさん人々に囲まれているんだけど
全然もうストレスというのは何ともならないんです
自由にいられるんです
またです ストレスと縁のない生き方ができます
ストレスというのはものすごい大変なことなんですよ
まあ私もストレスについての講演しましたけど
まあいろいろその時言いましたけど
ストレスはもう良いストレスも悪いストレスもありますよとかね
で これでまあすべての悪いストレスはなくなります
知らないことを皆喜んで教えてあげます
だから心配する必要ないんですよ
突然 もう計画もしないで外国旅行したってもね
大丈夫です みんな教えてくれるんです
英語も喋れなくて行っちゃったと
もう全然大丈夫です 記憶力
理解能力がスピードに上がります
この記憶能力を上げる方法っていうのは
もうこの喜びを感じる訓練なんです
集中力は向上します 知恵が徐々に現れます
一発じゃ現れませんけどね
徐々に現れます 心の汚れが徐々に少なくなってきます
汚れも知らんうちに落ちているんです
あの嫉妬やら怒り 落ち込み
憎しみとかね もういよいよ心喜びいっぱいだからね
もう入らないんです 解脱の門は開けます
そういう喜び感じる訓練
が これぐらいの利益があります
はい これで 5番目に行きます
あれは喜び感じる訓練しましょうと言って
それからこのどんな得あるのかいという説明でしたけどね
今はやり方なんですね
まず自分が気に入っている何人かを選びます
いきなり調子に乗るんじゃなくて
普段も自分が気に入っている何人かを選びます
一人でも構わない たくさんなかったら一人でも構わない
人間がいないならペットでも時々いますよ
寂しい人間はもう一人も知り合いはないとかね
もう一人ぼっちでペットだけいるんだったらペットでもいいんです
あるいはペットも飼ってないんだったら
そこら辺にいる動物でもいいんです
その生命の良いところを思い浮かぶ
心の中で微笑んでみる
これポイントです 例えば
自分にはペットもいないし
友達も知り合いもいないと思いましょう
私みたいに これで私が外を出ると
いろいろ人々が犬を散歩したりしますね
楽しいんですよ あれ見ると
いろんな犬がいろいろ性格があったりして
ああ いいな かわいいな
こいつは とかね ちらちらと見て楽しくなるんです
一回すごく面白かったのは
この小さな犬で 小さな小型の犬ですけど
いろいろ遅いんですね
あっちと止めて こっちだ止めて
もうもう散歩ですかね
あれはわからないんだけど
まあ犬は別に散歩してくれて歩んでるわけじゃなくて
犬はもう一応世界を見たいだけですけどね
鼻で見るんだからね 面倒くさいんですよ
時間かかります 目で見るならば一発で見えるのに
鼻で見るんだからちょっと時間かかりますけど
それであの甲州街道の郊外
交差点がありますね 私は中野通りにいますからね
これかなり幅があるんですよ
私は考えたのは この子はこのスピードでね
この青信号を渡るとちょっと間に合わないだろうなと思ったところで
青信号になった途端 こいつは勢いで走るんですよ
向こう側 あの飼い主がもう間に合う
もうなんとかして追っていくんですね
あ 賢いなと えらい賢いんだと
あの こう交差点を渡るところでは見学しないんですね
頭いいでしょ 車にぶつかったら大変なことになるんだから
そこで向こうに行ったとたん
またノロノロノロノロ
だから飼い主はそこまで知ってないでしょ
おそらく でも私は犬だけ見て楽しいんです
すごく楽しくなっちゃうんです
そこで飼い主はそこまで知らないだろうと思っちゃうと
色眼鏡が違うでしょ 他のデータも入っちゃった
だから色眼鏡をつけた方がいいんです
飼い主は無関心 あるいは飼い主もニコニコと犬と遊んでいるならば
まあその あ この人も相当楽しいだろうね
いい犬 犬を飼われてと
犬を飼うことができてとかね
そういうふうに喜びを感じるんです
感じて 心の中で微笑んでみてください
あのニコニコゲラゲラと笑わないでください
頭がおかしいと思います
私みたいにすごい厳しい顔をしていた方がいいんです
私は厳しい顔をしているのは
いろんな人がいて話しかけてくれるんですよ
あれは面倒くさくて しかし
心の中は違います むちゃくちゃ楽しんでるんです
そこをよくポイントを覚えてください
心の中で微笑んでみる
次に その相手がもっと幸せになったらいいなと思う
もっとそのふうにね 喜んで
あのワンちゃんの場合はね
よう元気で楽しく仲良くしてほしいなとかね
またいろいろゲーム またいろいろ学んでね
もうちょっと飼い主を喜ばせたりとかね
株が株が上がった方がいいなとかね
そういうふうに思うんです
それで まず他人のことを見て
自分が喜びを感じて微笑んでみて
それをもうちょっと拡張するんです
さらに 初期段階では 相手を選ぶとき気をつけましょう
もうやり方も説明しました
またポイントがあります
まず初期段階 始めた方は相手を選ぶときはちょっと気をつけた方がいいんです
性欲 愛着が引き起こせるような人を避けなくちゃいけないんです
大変なことになります
例えば男性がね 美人だけ選んで喜んでみようかなと
見て あの人がね スマートでかっこいいなとかね
胸があってとかね 腰が上がって
こんな感じでね まあいい
そんなこと思ってどうなるかわからないでしょ
だからそこはものすごく段々気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
性欲が引き起こすものはダメです
性欲も喜びは感じるかもしれませんだけど
これはカット それから愛着もダメなんです
微笑むところではなくなりますね
ですから 伴侶は良くない
なかなか伴侶に色眼鏡つけるのは難しいんで
悪い色眼鏡ばっかりでしょ
欠点だけ見る色眼鏡でしょ
つけているのは いいところだけ見る
色眼鏡をつけたらもうものすごい人生幸せですけどね
しかし 伴侶はダメっていうのはもうやっぱり性行為の相手でもありますから
これはちょっとまずいんです
それから我が子も良くないでしょうと思います
我が子には愛着が出てくるんだから
こいつはもっと頑張ればいいのにと思っちゃうでしょ
これは怒りになっているんですね
うちの子は本当に無茶可愛いんだけど
いいなとか 成長してほしいと思えるんだけど
もうちょっと頑張った方がいいんじゃない？こいつはと思っちゃうんで
だからこれもダメだと思います
無垢の微笑みが起こるような相手を選ぶなくちゃいけないんですね
私は前サンプル出したのはワンちゃんでしょ
別に愛着ってわけでもなくて
ただ可愛い いいな それで終わりでしょ
そんな贅沢ができない場合は
感情を控えて冷静に見られるようにします
無垢の愛着を感じる人
無垢の喜びを感じる人
誰かって見つからない場合は感情だけ控えてください
ただ微笑めば十分です
だから自分の子はダメですけど
他の子供 同じ年の子供たちを見てね
いいな その連中はね 楽しくてとかね
可愛いねとかね で 自分が微笑めばいいんです
それでうちの子と比較しちゃうと
もうこれかと感情が湧いてきます
正しい成長にならないんです
私も結構子供を見るんですよ
ただ見ただけで楽しくなっちゃうんです
選んだ相手の美徳 良いところ
気に入っているところ
長所ばかりをあえて思い浮かべる
それから実践にまた入ります
選んだ相手のいいところ
美徳 ああ これでこの人はこれができていいなとかね
これがこういうことがあってね
背が高くてよかったねとかね
スマートで細くていいねとかね
だから嫉妬するんじゃなくて
喜んで見る 微笑んで見る
短所が見えても直ちに無視する
色眼鏡でバイアスで見なくちゃあかんです
ちょっとレンズがちょっとおかしくなったと
さっさと拭いてまた直せばいいんです
短所より長所を拡大してみる
ちょっとイメージネーション使っても構わないんです
例えば すごくスマートで美人で
もう服 服のセンスも抜群で
歩き方もしゃべり方も完璧なすごいお嬢様が見たとしましょう
ああ この子は本当にいいねとかね
可愛いねとかね よくできてるんだとかね
性格は良くて 喋り方もすごく美しくて
手振り身振りはすごく綺麗でいいなとか
だからどんどんいろんな人々に愛されてほしいとかね
すごく優しい金の金回りがいい男に捕まってほしいとかね
ちょっとイメージ的に拡大しても構わないんですよ
それで自分の喜びが増えるでしょ
また この子と同じ可愛い子供で生まれたら
生まれたらいいなとかね
ちょっと拡張してみるんです
そうすると自分の喜びはあのイメージネーションで勝手に増えていくんです
また 相手が喜びを感じることも調べて
同感を作って微笑んでみる
そこで 時々が まあ人好きある場合はね
例えば自分がウナギが嫌いとしましょう
しかし この人はウナギが大好きねとかね
言って その人がウナギバクバク食べると結構楽しいでしょうねとかね
ちょっと考えて微笑んで見るんです
例えば我々は年寄りですけど
じゃあもうもう中学校の小学校の男のグループ見つかる
だから その男たちにとって楽しいっていうのは
蹴ったり踏んだり 走ったり
もういたずらしたりする世界でしょ
もう大人としては嫌なんですけど
やっぱり楽しいだろうなとかね
あ 決闘だ 競争だとか言いながらね
仲間同士でいろんなもう競争したりやって楽しんでるでしょ
そこで自分にはあまり楽しみないんだけど
本当のところ でも相手のことをちゃんと見て楽しむという訓練するんです
いわゆる同感する訓練ですね
はい モニターの八 次に対象になる生命の数を増やしてみるんです
今 最初に選んだ一人 二人か一人かもうわからない
それから数を増やしていくんです
友達の友達は皆友達でしょ
こういう方式でやるんです
我が子の仲間 皆我が子と同然というような
人の数を増やして 心で感じる喜びを増大する
例えば 自分には子供が一人しかいない
まだ小学生 それは小学生だからたくさん友達もいるでしょ
だから 子供一人分楽しむんじゃなくて
その小学校のクラスに例えば 20人いるならば
20人分を楽しめばいいんです
みんなもうみんな私の子やと
みんな可愛い可愛い 可愛いんだけど
まあいたずらするわ いろいろまあ楽しがってるんだからね
それでそれで成長するんだから
まあよかったよかったという風に
自分の喜びを人数を増やして増大するんです
自分の友達が一人かもしれませんだけど
との友達の友達がいるんだからね
あ こいつの仲間だから
みんないいやつやと そこでも自分の喜びを増やしてみるんです
この方法はリミットになるまで続くべきです
だから友達の友達のはっていうのは
あるところでリミットになっちゃうんですよ
これ以上見つからないということになるんで
できるだけ広げて広げて
喜びだけ増やしてみるんです
それから次のステップあるんです
モニターの九 親しい関係がない生命の美徳も感じるように
次のステップに入ります
別に親しくなくても 関係なくてもいいんです
他の生命にも広げてみるんです
例えば 公の場 集会場 電車
コンビニ デパートなどでも人と話してみる
全然関係ないでしょ 話してみるんです
何か楽しい短い会話 挨拶
冗談などを言ってみる
ちょっと楽しませてあげる
そこで自分が楽しむんです
はい この間 私はあの この間といっても
まあ 3日前かな あの 笹塚駅にはパン屋さんがいましてね
で どうしても買い物に行く時はかなりもう遅くなっちゃいますから
私の場合は で ちょっと大きいパン一つあって
私が買ううち いさな食パンはもうなくなってね
店は店しまい もうギリギリで行ったら
これ これ切ってくれる
スライスしてくれますか？って言ったらいいですよと
で どれぐらい大きさにしますか？と聞くんですね
それは私は知らんですよ
あの あの食パンのスライスしたら幅が何センチか何ミリかと
だから測ったことないんだよと言いたかったんですけど
これは失礼だから あの
あの 普通のこの 8枚切れの食パンがありますね
あの幅でいいんですよって言って
あ そうです  8枚  8枚切りって
あれはあの人 あれ 16枚に切っちゃうの
こんな感じに だから普通食パンよりちょっと大きかったんだから
あれ 2つで計算してね
もうこれこんな感じのパンになっちゃったんですけど
トースターに入れたらもうかなり黒いになっちゃうしね
そこでまあそれも切ってお金も払って
それからこの袋に入れる前に
あのレジの女の子が パンを見せてこれでいいんですか？と聞くんですね
それで私は一つ冗談言ってやろうと
これでダメと言ったってもうダメでしょうに
でも彼女はそんなに喜んだ記憶ないでしょう
分かんなくなっちゃって
はいはい いいです 大丈夫
それでいいですと言って
さっさと帰った 大失敗なんですね
私はちょっとからかったかったんですよ
偉そうに これでよろしいですか？いえ
これはダメですよって言ったらどうしますか
もう切ったパンでしょうに
だから私はこの余計な質問するなというタイプなんですけどね
だからマンネリ的に質問するんだけど
ほとんど無駄が多いなという
それは知恵の観察で でもそれでではなくて
ちょっと楽しくね この人もね
疲れているしね  1 日中仕事をして
うまくいかなかったんです
だから まあ時々私は結構初めて会ったって
店の人に何か何か変なことを言うんです
結構知識人の場合は結構受けますよ
医者に医者とかはもうとんでもないことを言っちゃうと
医者は知識人だからね
まあすごい喜んだりはします
自分に関係ない人々も観察して
美徳を発見の探検 これから美徳の発見
探検 美徳を発見する探検隊になってください
私はこれから人の生命の美徳を探検するんだよと言っても
調べればいいでしょう
結構いい研究になりますよ
やればやるほど楽しいんだから
自分が あの人にはこれができてよかったな
この猫さんにはこれができてよかったな
この猫さんがもう毛がボロボロですけど
なんかもういたずら好きな猫みたいでよかったなとかね
野良猫にたっても野良猫のにしっかり頑張ってるんですね
もうすごい精神的な強い強そうやとかね
とにかくこの美徳だけ発見する
探検するんです それから自分のことのように喜んでみるんです
ポイントは微笑むこと
いつでも自分が心で微笑むんです
はい  10番目 知恵の登場
関係のない人々 生命にもそれぞれの美徳があると発見できたところです
もう探検は終わった 終わったんじゃなくて
探検はかなり成功しました
そうすると やっぱりおかしいな
これは どんな生命にも何かしら美徳があるでしょうにと発見するんです
では 皆様はゴキブリの美徳を発見していないでしょう
私は発見していることはありますよ
蚊の美徳を発見したことがある
ほらない 私に聞いてみてください
発見していますよ で ヘビの美徳は？まあ
どうしようもないな じゃあこれから
これから発見してみてください
どんな生命の美徳も なんか動物いるでしょ？動物園に
人間近いとら ペッと唾かける
あれ臭いんですね なんとか名前のね
まあヤギみたいな 結構背が高くてね
私で見たら まあこれってかっこ悪いじゃないんで
私だったらこの野郎 もう唾液かけたいと思ってるでしょうにと
じゃあまあ見てみる 見てみろとかね
それで私にはその能力見えるんですね
人を狙って あの臭い唾液をかけたいんですね
で こちらそこは喜んで自分の生き方だから
身を守るためにやってるんであって
これって結構面白いやと
唾液かけさせて当たらないようにしたらどうですかとかね
それで私にはもう楽しい対象だけなんですね
だから普通人間には全然見つかりっこはない
もう嫌に嫌に決まってる生命であっても
私に聞いてみてください
こういう美徳あるんだよと
教えられます そういうことで結論に達するんですよ
生命みんなそれぞれ何かしら美徳を持ってるんだから
やっぱり生命っていうのは平等であると
区別差別できんやというところに達します
嫌な生命は存在しません
皆に何かしら美徳がある
可愛いところがある 評価するべきところがあるとわかるんです
この事実を身をもって発見するんです
観念ではなくて ちゃんと身をもって発見してほしいんです
はい では聞きます 嫉妬するところができる
全くもできんでしょう
全く念ないでしょう 最初から
はい これでもう講演は終了に入ります
あの常識ではないんで
これが この方法で感じる喜びは尋常でも常識でもないんです
普通の人間に普通に経験できるものでもありません
普通に生活したっても
これほどの喜び 幸福を感じることできないんですよ
だから想像できない 頭の中
心の中 もう楽しくて楽しくて
もうもうどうしようもない状態になってるはずなんです
何を見ても楽しい 何を見ても心の中でもうニコニコニコニコニコニコと
だから尋常じゃないんですよ
この喜びは 一般の人は突然大喜びを感じたら気を失ったり
泣き崩れたりします 例えば
今最近コマーシャルやってる
何でしたっけ？年末ジャンボ宝くじ
あれ 戦後一等賞当たったときたらもう倒れます
だってすごい喜びでしょ
時々テレビでもね なんとか何かでもう泣き崩れるんですね
耐久性のないんです 彼らの心に耐久性がないんです
弱 だからこの突然何かいいことが起きたっても
もう耐えられないんです
だから泣いたりするんです
泣くっておかしいでしょ？泣くっていうのは怒りで泣くんだからね
だから脳が異常現象を起こすんです
処理できなくて 脳に処理できなくなったんです
しかし このブッダのメソッドをやってみると
耐久性がしっかりできて
智慧が心がものすごく強く大きくなって拡大して
ものすごい強いんですよ
だからレコード大賞とそんなちっぽけな喜びじゃなくて
生命の数ある限り喜びを感じるんだから
並みじゃないんです その喜びは
はい 常識を超えるということで
ブッダの実践方法は完全安全な方法で
徐々に喜びを感じる範囲と量を増やしていくんです
今 お釈迦様の実践方法を皆様にわかるように教えたんです
こういうのはあんまり公に出してないんです
どこでも テキストにもないんだからね
伝統的に知ってるだけです
私も で これが完全安全な方法ですよ
全然病気にならない だから男の人は可愛い女の人の美徳を発見しようと思っちゃうととんでもない結果になるでしょ
そういうことじゃないんです
完全安全で喜びだけも拡大する
また全部タダですね それがいいでしょ
無料の生命を認識して喜びを感じるようになると
だからもう生命見て色眼鏡で見ると
もうもう耐え切れ 耐え
もう耐えれますけど 無料の喜びが湧き上がってくるんです
それで常識範囲を超えているんです
普通の人には決して感じられない喜びを感じられます
人間 どんな苦労したっても感じられない喜び
アメリカ人がアメリカンドリームをもう現実化したっても
こんな喜びは感じられません
心はボロボロの肉体から離れて機能するようになるんです
この喜びは肉体で感じるのは無理です
肉体はボロボロですからね
そんな力がないんです
ですから 心が肉体から離れて
この巨大化になって喜びを感じるんです
これはサマーディというんです
禅定に達します いたって簡単に
だから瞑想して禅定を作るためにえらい修行しなくちゃあかんでしょ
これっていたって簡単でしょ？そのままできるでしょ
それでもったいないというタイトルで終了します
私のノベル賞はくれませんだけどね
これほど簡単に究極的な喜びを感じられる方法があるのに
世界からいじめ 虐待 差別
嫉妬と憎しみ ストレスをなくす方法があるのに
戦地洗脳の神のように生きられる方法があるのに
人間の超越したしたですね
能力を表す方法があるのに
我々には超越した能力があるんですよ
この目に見えないぐらい
なんかもう細菌ぐらいの小さいんですから
これはどんどん大きくする方法はあります
これで 誰にでも実践できるのに
終わり で 動詞は皆様入れてください
私は文章は途中でやめたんです
のに まあまあ 丸々もったいない
はい まあそういうことで
まあいろいろ聞きたいこととかあるならば
何かご質問ある方挙手していただけましたら
マイクを貸してもらって
お話ありがとうございました
えっと 自我 自我というのは無明であるというふうに言われましたけれども
仏教と西洋哲学についてちょっと比較して
仏教の視点からどう見ているか
西洋哲学をどう見ているのかというのを
見解を伺いたいと思うのですけれども
例えば 以前に長老にブッダは何を悟られたのかというのを伺った時に
存在について悟られたんだというふうになりました
で 西洋の哲学でも存在について考えているわけですけれども
例えばフランスのデカルトは我思うゆえに我ありと言いました
この我思うゆえに我ありというのは
自我があるというようなことだと思うのですけれども
仏教の立場から言うと
自我があるというのは良くないことだということでしょうか
あれ？ あとですね 西洋哲学
現代の科学文明というのは
西洋の哲学に基づくというふうにも言うこともできると思うのですけれども
その科学技術については
例えば電気が付いて こういった通信技術が発展して
非常に我々は大きな恩恵を受けている一方で
例えば原子爆弾であったり
原子力発電所のメルトダウンであったりとかですね
悪い面も少なからずあるということですね
それと そのまあ 西洋哲学に基づく科学文明の発達のいい面
悪い面というのもあると思うんですけども
そういったことについて
仏教の視点からはどのように捉えておられるのでしょうか
デカルトみたいにね 我は思うゆえに我ありっていうのは
あれはもうラテン語で考えたんだから
あの変な錯覚に陥ったと思いますけどね
動詞の中に だから本当は思うゆえに我はあるという風にならなくちゃあかんですね
思うと言えば 日本語ではちょっと主語わからないんだから
我というふうに入れなく入れなくちゃいけないので
ラテン語ではそれは必要じゃないんですね
我々使っているインドアーリア言語家族はどちらでも同じ
動詞だけでも十分です
そこで勘違いしたでしょ
単純なミスでしょ それで私はニーチェやらもういろいろもう私の携帯にも入ってますけども
なんだこのアホヤと思って途中でやめちゃうんですね
ダラダラダラダラダラダラ
もうちょっとしたポイントを言うためにね
ものすごい時間かかって
またすごい頭がいいんだから
もう文章むちゃくちゃもう作って書くわ書くわ書くわ
もう頭いいのはいいんだけど
読む人の気持ちになってください
で やっぱり彼らがこの根本
あの前提があって思考しているでしょ
西洋哲学は 仏教はこの前提はおかしいと
前提調べましょうというところだけ違うんですね
例えば生きることは苦んと言っているようなクリシェやそんなのはもう現実調べればわかることで
あの実存主義 存も語った人々もね
とにかくどこかで壁にぶつかって終わるでしょ
だから彼らがこのある前提があって
これは人間誰でも同じなんですね
それから思考するんです
仏教は思考もすべて捏造やと言ってるんだから
まあはっきり言います
全部ゴミです 思考そのものは捏造だからね
まずありのままに捏造しないでデータを受け取らなくちゃいけないんですね
それから前提は合ってるかないかと調べなくちゃいけないんですね
だからお釈迦様も生きるとは何？あるいは我とは何？というところの研究なんですよ
我はいるんではなくて
我とは何？なんです そうなってくると
原因必至性やらもう住職
色情商業式とかね 因果法則とか
あれやこれや カラクリ
カラクリ カラクリ このコンピューターみたいに
インターネットみたいに
あれやこれやとカラクリできているということをわかっただけで
我はどこにも見当たらない
だからどこにも見当たらないよと
しかし 認識範囲はこれだけやと
これ以上は成り立たんやと
いうことになったんです
それで心が明らかになって
解放 問題解決しまったということになったんですね
で  2番目忘れちゃった
あの科学技術  科学と はいはいはい
あの まああの科学者ってあれが人間で
やっぱり貪瞋痴の衝動で動いてるんだから
貪瞋痴は必ず夢を作るんですよ
しょうがないんですよ
例えば欲で金儲かるといろんなものを犠牲にしちゃってるんですよ
ものすごくライバル国に対して敵意を持って戦いますよ
その場合は我を忘れて
でもものすごい自分損害受けてますよ
ですから 例えば原子力発見
あの あの なんてあの化学物質を発見したところで
これってすげえエネルギーだろうと思っただけでしょ
それからそこから欲に走っちゃったんですね
研究していないんです
いきなり爆破して膨大なエネルギーは作ります
想像できないエネルギーは作れます
それで湯沸かし器を作って古い技術でしょうに
湯沸かし器を作ってスチームでタービンを回すことは全然先進技術でも何でもないんです
しかし 原子力ってどんなものか
どう管理するのか 最低核廃棄物をどう処理するのかと
いまだにないでしょ アメリカにもフランスにもイギリスにも
こんなものは溜まって溜まってどうするんですかね
だから欲に走っちゃったでしょ
そうすると膨大な矛盾が生まれて
膨大な損が起きてくるんですよ
何でもいいんですよ フェイスブックにしたっても
いろんな人とコンタクトできてよかったと
よかったんですけど 同時にとんでもないことが起きるんですね
それはまあ 本能は貪瞋痴だからなんです
だから解決方法は貪瞋痴を慈悲喜捨に入れ替えることなんです
それは西洋では解かれていないんです
はい  この方 ではそちらの中段の女性の方
今日はありがとうございました
実践していきたいと思うんですけれども
その時にこれから日常生活とかで嫉妬が出てきた時に
誰か好きな人を追いかけて
自分が心の中で微笑めば
その嫉妬の心は消散されたっていう風に考えていいんでしょうか
はいはい その通りです
ありがとうございます
とにかく微笑みを感じてください
もう偏見で構わない とにかく微笑んでみると
嫌な気持ちはもう取り入れませんと
いう色眼鏡で頑張ればもう綺麗に消えます
どうぞ 向こうの方ですね
今日は貴重なお話 ありがとうございました
えっと 私はこう 毎日の生活の中で
こう 自分の心の声に素直に
こう 自分の心の声がなかなか聞こえなくて
人と交わると それがたといいことであっても
知らぬ間に後でこう感情が揺れてしまったり
何があって 自分の心の声に従って
こうそのまま行動するとか
そういうことがなかなか難しくて
怯まってるっていうか
考えてしまうことが多いんですけれども
うーん 自分のこう 自然のありのままの自分っていうか
こう毎日心を見るには
見るにはっていうか まあどうしたらよろしいでしょうか
ちょっとアドバイスだけがあって
はい こういう状態の の場合はね
まあ自分の国から見れば
言えばなんか女性に良く悪ことやと思いますけど
でも日本の社会ではね
これはもう男女問わず
そういう精神状態っていうのはね
結構あります まあ周りの色に染めるだけで
自分って何やということはわからなくなっちゃっちゃうっていう状態なんですね
で これはじゃあ仏教心理学的に説明しますけど
あのちょっと無知の方が強いんですね
貪瞋痴の中で 無知っていうのはいくつでも曖昧で中途半端で
はっきり何も決めないで
例えば怒り欲あるとはっきり決めます
物事はこれが欲しい あなたは嫌とかね
はっきりしています で
それより無知の方が優先になってくると
まあまあとかどうかなという状態になっちゃうんですね
だからアイデンティティ探してる連中も
結局無知の方がすごく強すぎなんですね
あの怒りも欲もよりはね
で 無知は大胆なことはしないんだけど
結局はそのままズルズルと人生不幸にしちゃうっちゃうんですね
例えばイッカジュカできちゃうと大胆なことをするんですよ
してそこで破壊しますからね
爆発しちゃって 欲が出てきたら
欲に絡む 頭がおかしくなっちゃうと
なんか大胆なことをしてそれで破壊しますけど
で 無知っていうのは大胆なことさせませんだけど
ズルズルズルズルズルズルと
もう人の道を壊して それから何もできない状態にさせちゃうんですね
結局は家 部屋からも出られなくなってしまうとかね
という状態になっています
だから まず  これは理論的な説明でね
無知の感情がちょっと働いてるんだっていうことなんですね
はい これ何とかしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから この私は誰でしょうかと
私の心の声は聞こえませんというふうな
この神秘的な言葉を捨ててください
いらん こんなのは 科学的に見てみればいいでしょう
私はどこかで言ったね
心の声だけ聞くなよと
心の声ってとんでもないんですよ
だってわがままでいい加減で
もう自分だけ偉いと思っていていう心でしょ
心に正直に聞いてみれば
嫌な連中 みんな死んでしまえという気持ちでしょ
金ならいくらでも入れという気持ちでしょ
だから心の声は聞くもんじゃないんです
心はすごく汚くて良くないんです
だからそれは答えじゃないんですね
やり方は 我々はせっかく生きているということは
なんで生きているのかというと苦しみからなんですけど
我々は幸福を探しているんですね
だからじゃあ幸福に生きることが私の生き方よと決めてください
それで OK です 幸福で生きること
それにはその都度その都度幸福を見つかりますよと
例えば 人々と話していると
みんな嫌なことばっかり言ってると
自分がその波に乗っちゃうでしょ
これは幸福じゃ私は嫌ですからね
そんな話はと 気持ち悪いよ
楽しくないよと言った方がいいんですね
それで自分が幸福を探してるんだからね
もう楽しい話しろよと言っちゃえばいいんです
うん だから人間なら 生命なら誰でも幸福を探しているんです
ですから その風に目的決めて生きてみてください
それで OK 無知が機能しなくなります
はい  温かいことがここだと思います
本当にありがとうございます
はい  もう 1人の方 手を挙げている男性の方が中段の方の
男性の方が早かったような気がします
はい  この方にあげていただいて
その方です  えっと あの
自分以外の生命 動物とか生命に対して喜びを感じる練習を徐々に広げていく
範囲を広げていくということだったんですけども
いきなりは無理だと思うんですけど
最終的には例えば極端な例なんですけど
凶悪な犯罪者とか あるいはものすごく苦しんでいる人
病気で苦しんでいるとか
犯罪に巻き込まれて苦しんでいるとか
災害で苦しんでいるとかっていう人を見ても
何か何かしらいいこととか喜びを感じるようなことは可能なんでしょうか
あの かなり成長してたら可能です
最初はもう絶対無理ですし
やってはいけないんですね
最初は簡単に喜びを感じる人を選んで実践するんです
あの 成功すると 生命たるものはみんな何かしら何かしら美徳あるんだよということが見えてくるんです
例えば極悪犯罪者にしても
その私はあまり公で言いたくないんですけど
いろいろあるんですね
まずやっているんだから
やっぱり見つかるんです
別に犯罪は正当化しているわけじゃないんです
かわいそうやと あの 要は喜だけですけど
慈悲喜捨という修行する
4つもありますからね
だからこのアホがなんてやったんですか？なんて自分の大事な人生をね
ダメにしたんですかとと思いますよ
で それから自分がそんなにも生きていられないなら
一人勝手に死ねばよかったでしょうにと
なんで人まで道連れにするのかという気持ちはあるんだけど
しかし 何の能力もない
美徳もないということではないんですね
あのテロリストがいるでしょ
イスラム教の みんな若い連中でしょ
二十歳代で あるいは二十歳にもなってない
10代でね あれでよく勇気あるんだなとか思いますよ
もう生きていきたい年でしょうに
女の子遊びたい 生きていきたいとかね
もういろんなことをやりたいし
夢いっぱいある子供たちでしょ
それでもじゃあもう入れますというね
もうこれぐらいやる気があれば
お前らにはいろんなことできたでしょうにと思っちゃうんですね
だからこの実践した人には見つかることはできます
だいたい昨日瞑想の場合は
そういうのは一応カットしますよ
だって色眼鏡でやってますからね
カットします それで成功したら一人前になったら
まあ別に探そうと思っちゃえば見つかるんです
例えば自爆テロの人も幸福を探してるでしょ？自分の人々を助けてあげますと思ってるでしょ
アメリカという悪魔の国のせいでイスラム人が悪く
自分たちのせいなんですけどね
もうアホもいいところですけど
殺し合いやってるの互い同士ですけど
アメリカは大したことやってないしね
でもアメリカのせいだといきなり言うんですね
そこで真に受けちゃって
自分の仲間 自分の宗教を信仰する人々を助けてあげなくちゃいけない
アッラさんを助けてあげなくちゃいけないとかね
と思ってるんだからね
いい子たちですよ かえって考えてみれば
偉いビジョンでも変なビジョンですけど
本人の立場から見ればすごく偉いビジョン持ってるでしょ
だからまあ私なら見つかるんですよ
今 私の見方言ったんです
皆様も同じ見方にならなくても構わないんだけどね
だから私は悲しいんだけど
なんで若者がね こうなるのかと
イランで イランがイラクと戦争した時やったんですね
その時はものすごく悲しかったんですね
イラン人っていうのはみんな一般的にみんな美男美女なんですね
なんかよくわからないんです
まあアーリア民族のもとだとというんですからね
結局は 特にこの二十歳以下の連中は結構すごいかっこいいんですよ
そこでもうもうもうかわいくてたまらない
かわいい男たち 子供たちがね
お母さんたちが喜んでお祭りをして戦争に出すんですよ
国のためにアラという
アッラーというおバカ者のために死んでくれと
戦ってくれと そこでイラクに行ったところで殺されるでしょう
それからむちゃくちゃ泣き崩れるんですね
許せませんよと これはとか
何を言うのか お前はと
戦争にだったら死ぬか死なれるかどちらかわからないでしょうに
だからすごいアホなんですけど
それで私は悲しくなる
なんでこの若者たちは
こんなかっこいい男たちがね
もう勉強して仕事を見つけて
いい相手と結婚したら
どれほど楽しく長生きできるのかいと思っちゃうんですね
やっぱりそれでも自分の将来をすべて親の言葉になりますからね
これでさすがいい子でしょ
自分の将来 未来 すべて
親の言葉を聞いて はい
わかりました 捨てますと
だからいい子たちなんですよ
結局は そういうことで
ムディタの実践して成長すれば
どんなものにも美徳を見つかります
しかし 勘違いしないでください
極悪犯罪者を正当化するではないんです
戦争は正当化するのではないんです
テロ行為を正当化するのではないんです
人間みんな平和で幸せで生きてほしいんです
頭がいかれて極悪犯罪を起こす人々も
その環境のせいでそうなっちゃうでしょうに
だから我々は 我々はより優しくなって
人々にもっと優しくして
問題があったら解決してあげて
話し合ってあげて 仲良くワイワイと生きることができれば
極悪犯罪なくなるでしょう
ですから そこは別な視点で見るとそうなるんです
一応皆様方は簡単に美徳を感じられる人から実践を始めてみてください
はい  苦しんでいる病気ですごく負義があるとか苦しんでいる
その場合は慈悲喜捨の悲を実践するんだから
だいたいカットします
で 苦しんでいる人々を見てもムディタやりたいというのは無理ですけど
余計な無理をすると瞑想にならないんですね
苦しんでいる人々の場合は
この苦しみは何とかしてほしいというカルナを
憐れみの気持ちを育てなくてはいけないので
これ決まってます 瞑想はちゃんと
苦しんでいる人の場合でも
やりたいと思うならば
よく頑張ってますよ みんな
例えば東北の人々は落ち着いて頑張っているところは見事でしょ
あれは人間の業じゃないでしょ
考えてみれば すべて失っちゃって
何もなくて 財産を失ったっても我慢できますけど
家族も親も失っちゃって
子供たちが でも頑張ってます
笑ってます あの精神の強さっていうのはね
すごいでしょ 喜べますよ
だから 何かしら見つかるんですよ
その気になれば しかし
実践上は我々は推薦しません
極悪犯罪者とかね 苦しんでいる人とか推薦しないと
徐々にタクティカル的に育てなくちゃいけないので
こんな遊びじゃないんです
いい加減で世間の話に乗ったらダメです
テレビのあれ 何でしたっけ？この世の中聞いたあかん
あんなのはブッダの話じゃないんだからね
皆様 そういうものに釣られてますよ
だから世の中をいっぺんに観察するようなつもりで
あれ 色眼鏡じゃなくて乱視の眼鏡なんです
何も一つ見えません すべてぐちゃぐちゃになっているんです
だからどうすればいいかわからないんですよ
だっていっぺんに考えてください
世の中でね 大成功する人もいるし
ノーベル賞を取る人もいるし
極悪犯罪者もいるし むちゃくちゃ苦しんでいる人もいるし
日本と違ってね このアフリカとかね
本当にもうどうにもならん苦しんでいる人々いるでしょ
今 海賊やってるあの何国でしたっけ？モザンビーク
スーダン え？スーダンでもう一つ国がありますね
あの  somalia ソマリア
とか ソマリア海賊はいるんだけど
一般人はもうとんでもない苦しみで生きてるんですよ
もう誰に殺されるかわからないし
もうむちゃくちゃなんですね
だからそういうものを全部一遍に見たら
私はどうすればいいか分からなくなるでしょ
だからこの変な人々のこの知識かぶりは良くないんです
あんなのは知識じゃなくて知識かぶりなんです
もう何でも喋ってやるぞとかね
結局は何の結論もなく終わっちゃうんです
ブッダはそうじゃなくて
すごい丁寧に この脳の手術するような感じで
すごい丁寧に性格を直すのを教えているんです
だから今日私は精密にこのやり方を教えたんだから
この通りにやるしかないんです
はい  ありがとうございました
はい では お時間がだいぶ過ぎてきましたので
今お手上げいただいた方で最後に
はい はい 真っすぐ あの女性の方
あと 2人ですか？いや
あと 2人ではない  すいません
あの 私は数年前 一応危篤になったことがありまして
危篤になった 死にかけたことがありまして
その時はすごくこの激しい痛みと呼吸困難とかでパニックになってしまって
で なんか気付きを入れるとか
全然そんな余裕がないような状態になってしまったんですけれども
で 今ちょうどのお話とかよく聞くようになって
今あの今の人生で少しでも悟りに近づきたいと思ってるんですけれども
そう願うんだったら その最後
死ぬ最後のその苦しい時間というか
痛みとかで苦しい時間に何をすべきなのかというか
どうやって心を落ち着けさせたらいいのかを教えていただきたいんですけれども
なんか先生わからなかった
1年前ですよね そういうことかな
あの  5年前 あの 一回危篤状態になって
危篤状態 死に死にそうな状況になって
で その時に心にすごい波があって混乱してしまったってことなんですけど
そういう苦しみに見舞われた時に
どうすれば心が安定していただけるか
というまあ 終わったことは終わったにしてください
もう終わっちゃったとね
もうなんでも振り返ってくると思わない方がいいんです
ですから まあそれは全然気にすることはないんですよ
終わったことだからね
その時どんな精神状態だったって
もういいや もうそんなのは
で これからできれば今日の瞑想はね
まあやってみて 微笑んで生きてみるとかね
そういうふうにやってみたらいいんじゃないかなと思いますよ
すごい精神的に混乱に陥った時とか
いろいろあるんでしょう
歌ったりとかね 歌ってみるとかね
まあどこかにちょっと散歩に出るとかね
旅に出るとかね まあちょっと地方に行ってみるとかね
海に行くとかね というふうに
なんとかすれば楽に取ってください
あまり真剣に物事を取らない方がいいんです
だから今日の瞑想はとってもとってもやりやすいと思います
あの かつて起こしたことをまた起こったらどうしようかというのは余計な心配です
それはもういらん というふうにした方がいいと思います
はい じゃああの  はい お話ありがとうございます
本日のお話の中で 欲や怒りは発展の起爆剤ではないとおっしゃられましたが
何を発展の起爆剤とされるのでしょう
やっぱり慈しみですよ
人々の役に立つことをしてあげたいというと
いくらでもエネルギーが出ます
それだけ  ありがとうございます
金儲かりたくてと欲でしょ
あまり儲からないんです
だから あのジョブズさんみたいに
とんでもないいいもの作りたいとかね
でもむちゃくちゃ まあ彼が性格悪いんだからね
いろんな人にすごい邪魔わせちゃったんですけど
でも彼が哲学が貫いているんだから
みんな一応応援するんですね
とにかく人が喜ぶことをやりたいんだと
そういうふうに人に役に立つことをしたいということは
すごい起爆剤になります
それではよろしいでしょうか
だいぶ時間が過ぎましたので
これで終了したいと思います
最後に皆さんと回向の文を行って終了したいと思います
では合掌してください
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に大拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして苦悩が消えますように
サッビーティヨー ヴィヴァンジャントー サッバローゴー ヴィナッサトゥ マーテー バワッタントラーヨー スケーディーガー
ユコー バヴァー バウタサッバマンガラーン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバブンダヌバーヴェーナ サッバダンマ
ヌバーヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティバヴァントゥテー アビワダナシーリスー ニッチャンワッダパチャ
ヤーイナー チャッターロー ダンマー ワッダンティー アユーワンノー スカンバラン
サーーサーーサー  はい
ありがとうございます